Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der Metaebene in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Und ich begrüße alle hier zur 60. Ausgabe, wo wir mal wieder mehr ins wissenschaftliche Feld abtauchen wollen, was sozusagen auch dort der Stand der Dinge ist. Und ganz konkret wollen wir auch das Sonnensystem ein wenig verlassen und weit nach außen blicken. So ganz am Rande war das hier auch an verschiedenen Sendungen schon mal ein Thema, aber so richtig im Fokus war es eigentlich bisher noch nie. Die Rede ist von Exoplaneten oder extrasolaren Planeten, also Planeten anderer Sonnensysteme. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartnerin Heike Rauer vom DLR.
Schönen guten Tag.
Frau Rauer, Sie sind beim DLR hier in Berlin, Standort Adlershof, Institut für Planetenforschung. Da hatte ich ja schon so einige Gäste hier bei Raumzeit. Sie sind die Abteilungsleiterin für den Bereich extrasolare Planeten und Atmosphären. Das wäre so ein blumiger Titel.
Wie das immer so ist.
Haben Sie den ausgesucht?
Ich fürchte, ich habe ihn ausgesucht. Er spiegelt ein bisschen die historische Entwicklung mit meiner Themenfelder wieder. Die von den Kometen, Gas, Komi, die man im weitesten Sinne Atmosphären nennen kann, hingegen zu den Exoplaneten und deren Atmosphären und deren Entdeckung.
Sie haben ja auch noch ein zweites Standbein bei der TU Berlin. Was ist dort Ihre Rolle?
Ja, ich bin Naturschullehrer für das Fach Planetare Physik. Sodass auch die Studenten mit extrasolaren Planeten und den Planeten des Sonnensystems in Kontakt kommen und dort etwas darüber lernen können.
Wie sind Sie denn jetzt zu diesem ganzen Themenkomplex gekommen? Hören Sie auch so zu der Generation, die sich nichts Schöneres vorstellen konnte, als möglichst weit Kontakt mit der Außenwelt aufzunehmen oder sind Sie auch eher als Quereinsteiger in die Raumfahrt-Thematik gekommen?
Nein, die Thematik der extrasolaren Planeten sind wir alle als Quereinsteiger gekommen. Dieses Thema gibt es erst seit ungefähr 20 Jahren. Ich selbst habe mich seit meiner Promotion mit Kometenphysik beschäftigt. Darüber haben Sie vielleicht auch schon gehört, über die Rosetta-Mission hier im Podcast.
Ja, die ist schon mehrfach ausführlich besprochen worden.
Genau, ein sehr, sehr spannendes Thema. Aber die Kometen, warum beschäftigt man sich mit Kometen? Weil man etwas über die Entstehung des Sonnensystems lernen möchte. Als 1995 der erste Planet um einen anderen Stern entdeckt wurde, habe ich gedacht, das ist erstens unheimlich faszinierend und zweitens, wenn wir jetzt Planetensysteme einer großen Zahl kennen werden, die vielleicht ganz vielfältig sind, dann lernen wir ja noch viel, viel mehr über Planetenentstehung und wir können unser Sonnensystem und dessen Entstehungstheorie mit anderen Systemen vergleichen. Das fand ich so spannend, dass ich mein Thema dahin erst mal erweitert habe und heute ist es so, dass ich mich hauptsächlich mit extrasolaren Planeten beschäftige.
Aber wie sind Sie denn überhaupt zum Thema Raumfahrt gekommen?
Zum Thema Raumfahrt, über meine Promotion und ehrlich gesagt über die Kindheit. Ich wollte auch mal Astronaut werden und ich fand auch Science Fiction spannend und diese Thematik natürlich.
Was haben Sie dann studiert?
Ich habe Physik studiert in Hannover. Da gab es keine Astrophysik, keine Astronomie. Jetzt habe ich da mit meiner Promotionsstelle Glück gehabt, in dem Bereich eine Stelle zu bekommen und dann dort angefangen. Zunächst mit bodengebundenen Teleskopen. Also ich habe auch viel bodengebundene Beobachtungen gemacht, astronomische Beobachtungen gemacht. Sehr, sehr spannend. Und bin dann hier am DLR immer mehr in die Raumfahrt gekommen.
Also dann mehr oder weniger direkt von der Uni auch schon beim DLR gelandet?
Nein, nein. Ich habe ein Max- Planck-Institut Vironomien in der Nähe von Göttingen und an der Uni Göttingen promoviert. War dann in Paris zwei Jahre, dort am Observatorium. Und bin dann 1997 hier nach Berlin ans DLR gekommen. Schon eine lange Zeit jetzt.
Also das Thema waren zunächst einmal die Kometen.
Genau, das Thema waren die Kometen und 1995 wurden die extrasolaren Planeten entdeckt, der erste, damals noch sehr umstritten. Ich war zu der Zeit in Paris und in Frankreich war die, wie soll ich es sagen, die Begeisterung sehr schnell sehr stark. Es war klar, dass es faszinierend ist, dass es eine Erweiterung unseres Themas ist. Und ich hatte Glück, ich bin auf dem Weg vom Restaurant von der Kantine zum Büro, habe ich einen älteren Kollegen getroffen, wir haben uns darüber unterhalten. Er hat gesagt, schreib doch einen Beobachtungsantrag für den damaligen Infrarot-Satelliten, den es gab. Da bin ich so in dieses Thema hineingerutscht. Das war damals eine große Begeisterung und aufregend, ein neues Forschungsgebiet. Wann hat man das schon mal als Wissenschaftler heute, dass sich ein völlig neues Feld auftut? Das passiert einem ja nur einmal im Wissenschaftlerleben und überhaupt nur, wenn man Glück hat.
Welcher Satellit war das?
Das war der ISO, Infrared Space Observatory, damals. Er war in so einer letzten Zeit, das war also gerade so, man konnte das letzte Mal Anträge stellen. Wir haben natürlich nichts beobachtet. Heute muss ich sagen, Blödsinn. Ja, die Messgrenze war viel zu hoch. Der war einfach nicht empfindlich genug gegenüber dem, was man heute weiß. Aber es war halt Aufbruchsstimmung, man wusste nicht und man dachte, okay, wir probieren das einfach mal aus, vielleicht messen wir was.
War denn das überraschend damals, 95, dass diese Entwicklung gemacht wurde oder hatte man schon die ganze Zeit das Gefühl, so jetzt müsste man aber eigentlich dem nächsten Mal was finden oder war das immer noch so ein bisschen die Nadel im Heuhaufen und man wusste gar nicht, ob man die richtigen Instrumente hat?
Die Entdeckung wurde ja gemacht von unseren Kollegen in der Schweiz, Michel Major und Didier Kélos und einem amerikanischen Team gleich danach, Geoff Marcy und Jeff Butler. Die haben mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmetode, da können wir gleich drüber reden, über die Methoden, diesen Planeten entdeckt. Diese Methode war schon lange bekannt, man hat damit Doppelsterne beobachtet, also zwei Sterne, die um einander kreisen und deren Massen bestimmen wollen. Diese Methode hat eine lange Tradition, aber die Messgrenzen waren zu groß. Sie wurden mit der Zeit immer weiter runtergetrieben, bis man in den Bereich kam, dass man nicht nur einen Stern messen konnte, der einen anderen umkreist, sondern einen Planeten, der einen anderen umkreist. Das Überraschende war, dass dieser Planet eine halbe Jupiter-Masse schwer war oder schwer ist und eine Umlaufperiode hat von ungefähr vier Tagen. Das war der Planet 51 Pegasus B. B steht für den Planeten, A wäre der Stern, B ist der Planet. Eine halbe Jupiter-Masse und vier Tage Umlaufperiode, das war damals unvorstellbar. Als ich das gehört habe, habe ich es auch erst mal nicht glauben können, weil eine halbe Jupiter-Masse damit war klar, das kann kein Gesteinsplanet sein, das muss ein Gasplanet sein. Und Gasplaneten mit so kurzen Umlaufperioden, die dann entsprechend nah an ihrem Stern sein müssen, sehr, sehr nah, viel näher als Merkur bei uns, die so nah an ihrem Stern sind, das sollte eigentlich so nicht sein, denn sie sollten dort nicht entstehen können.
Warum nicht?
Ja, da kann ich ein bisschen in die Planetenentstehung ausholen. Die Planetenentstehungstheorie hat sich natürlich bisher an dem Planetensystem orientiert, das man kannte, das war nur eins, nämlich unser Sonnensystem. Und die groben Bausteine der Theorie sind auch recht gut verstanden und allgemein akzeptiert. Die Planeten bilden sich gleich nachdem sich der Stern gebildet hat. Ein Stern bildet sich aus einer Gaswolke und Gasstaubwolke, die kollabiert, das bildet sich der Stern. Aber nicht alles Material landet im Stern, sondern das ganze System kollabiert nicht einfach, sondern es fängt an sich zu drehen. Um einander der Stern dreht sich dann und um den Stern herum bildet sich eine Gas- und Staubscheibe, die den Stern umläuft. In dieser Gas- und Staubscheibe bilden sich dann relativ schnell die Planeten. Das heißt aber, wenn ich Planeten bilden will aus Gas und Staub, muss ich irgendwie das Material kondensieren in Brocken, die anwachsen können, bis sie Planetengröße haben. Dazu muss es hinreichend kalt sein. Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn man sehr nah an dem Stern ist, ist es zunächst mal sehr heiß. Wenn ich sehr nah am Stern bin, habe ich Temperaturen über 1000 Grad. Wenn ich Gestein kondensieren will, ansammeln wir hier Staub, das geht dort. Aber für Gas ist es dort einfach zu zu heiß. Sie wissen, wenn ich Eis bilden will, muss es 0 Grad sein, was im Moment bei uns in Berlin nicht ist. Also sie müssen Temperaturen haben unter 0 Grad und die haben sie einfach im inneren Bereich dieser Gas- und Staubscheibe nicht. Dazu kommt noch, dass der junge Stern einen Sternwind hat. Das heisst, er imitiert Teilchen, Atome, die das Gas im inneren Bereich einfach wegblasen. Das innere Bereich dieser Scheibe ist also frei von Gas und wenn dort welches wäre, könnte es dort gar nicht zu Eis kondensieren. Das bedeutet, dass ich in diesem inneren Bereich der Scheibe nur Staub habe. Das heisst, ich kann Planeten bilden, die hauptsächlich aus Silikaten, also Staub, bestehen. Und das sieht man ja auch im Sonnensystem. Unser Sonnensystem hat Merkur, Venus, Erde, Mars, die inneren Planeten. Das sind alles Gesteinsplaneten. Die haben zwar zum Teil eine Atmosphäre, Venus und Erde, eine Dünne der Mars, aber die Atmosphäre, der Anteil der Masse, die Atmosphäre an der Planetenmasse ist verschwindend gereingeringen. Hauptsächlich bestehen die aus Gestein. Und das passt, das passt mit dieser Vorstellung zusammen. In dieser inneren Scheibe gab es kein Gas mehr, da gab es nur den Staub. Und der Staum hat sich dann, die Staubteile haben sich aneinander angelagert und sind gewachsen. Schließlich hat man ein Planet. Ich mache das jetzt sehr einfach. Das ist natürlich in Wirklichkeit kompliziert, aber im Prinzip ist es so. Dann gibt es diese berühmte Eislinie, das heißt, dass der Abstand vom Stern, in dem es dann kalt genug wird, so dass auch das Gas kondensieren kann. Und diese Eislinie befindet sich im Sonnensystem so ungefähr zwischen Mars und Jupiter.
Also da, wo der Asteroidengürtel ist.
Da, wo der Asteroidengürtel ist. Ein bisschen drüber hinaus. Genau. Und wenn sie dann ins äußere Sonnensystem schauen, was sehen sie dort für Planeten? Sie sehen die Gasplaneten, die aus Wasserstoff bestehen. Wasserstoff mit Helium und verschiedenen Spurenstoffen. Und diese Gasplaneten haben Monde. Und diese Monde haben zum grossen Teil eine dicke Eisschicht. Das heißt, man sieht schon, dass das äußere Sonnensystem ganz anders aufgebaut ist als das innere Sonnensystem. Im äußeren Sonnensystem haben wir Planeten und Monde mit flüchtigen Materialien, die dort kondensieren konnten und in die Planeten eingebaut wurden oder aus denen sich die Planeten dann auch gebildet haben. So, und das passt dann wunderbar. Das war auch die Erwartungshaltung, die man an andere Planetensysteme hatte, weil das klingt ja einleuchtend und macht Sinn. Innen habe ich keinen Gas und Staub mehr, also bilde ich dort die Gesteinsplaneten. Außen habe ich noch Gas und flüchtige Materialien, die können kondensieren, zu ausfrieren sozusagen und die können dann eingebaut werden in die Planeten. Das passt gut. Und jetzt hat man einen Planeten gefunden, der in einem Abstand vom Stern ist, weit innerhalb der Merkobahn. Vier Tage Umlaufperiode, im Prinzip noch in der Sonnenatmosphäre sich bewegt sozusagen. Und der passt nicht in diese Theorie. Verstehen Sie? Der kann sich dort nicht gebildet haben, weil da sollte ja gar kein Gas sein, um dort einen Gasriesen zu bilden.
Was hat denn diejenigen, die das beobachtet haben, so sicher gemacht, dass es hierbei um einen Gasplaneten handeln muss?
Na ja, wenn Sie einen Planeten haben mit einer halben Jupiter-Masse. Also Jupiter hat 318 Erdmassen. Wenn Sie mal Erdmassen umrechnen, wenn Sie das halbieren, dann sind Sie immer noch bei 160 Erdmassen. Wir können uns nicht vorstellen, dass ein Gesteinsplanet zu groß wachsen kann. Das liegt daran, wenn ein Gesteinsplanet mehr als zehn Erdmassen groß ist, dann fängt er an, wenn Gas um ihn herum ist, das Gas zu akkretieren. Das heißt, wir können bis ungefähr zehn Erdmassen ein Gesteinsplaneten erzeugen und danach fängt er an, die Wasserstoffatome in seiner Umgebung anzusammeln und es wird ein Gasplanet. Und das geht wieder sehr schnell. Das heißt, es gibt so zwei Klassen im Prinzip. Sie haben Gesteinsplaneten bis zu einer bestimmten Größe und danach haben sie Gasplaneten.
Das heißt, wenn die Erde quasi wachsen würde, dann würde einfach ihre Masse so stark werden, dass einfach das Gas sehr viel mehr angezogen wird.
Genau, weil je mehr massereich sie sind, desto mehr Material ziehen sie an. Muss natürlich Material da sein, aber... Also mit einer halben Jupiter-Masse können wir uns nur vorstellen, dass es ein Gasplanet ist. Heute haben wir auch noch andere Beobachtungsmethoden, sowas zu bestätigen. Aber damals war das die Erwartungshaltung, die sich auch bestätigt hat.
Aber ist das dann nicht so ein bisschen so eine Situation wie bei so einem Doppelsternsystem, wo ja im Prinzip auch so zwei Gas...
Ja, das ist richtig. Also sie haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder sie bilden den Planeten doch da, wo er ist, auch wenn man das nicht erwartet. Zum Beispiel, indem er sich gleichzeitig mit dem Stern bildet, wie ein Doppelsternsystem. Also im Prinzip ein sehr ungleiches Doppelsternsystem eben. Oder sie müssen den Planeten da hinbringen. Es gibt auch diese beiden Theorien im Prinzip, aber diese ungleiche Bildung von seinem ungleichen System direkt im Kollaps scheint unwahrscheinlich, unwahrscheinlicher, schwieriger zu machen, als den Planeten dorthin zu bringen. Es hat sich nämlich danach gezeigt, nach dieser Entdeckung. Und nachdem all die Kritik, die die reine Messung bestätigen musste, überwunden war, man wusste ja, der Körper ist tatsächlich da und er hat auch diese Masse. Danach hat sich herausgestellt, dass bei den Theoretikern, die Simulationen machen, um Planeten-Systeme zu bilden, man macht das im Computermodelle, man nimmt eine Scheibe an, man nimmt die Prozesse an, mit denen sich daraus Planeten bilden und dann kann man eine Simulationsrechnung machen. Das hat sich dann gezeigt, dass in ganz vielen Fällen, oder sehr oft, im Normalfall, wenn ich einen Gasplaneten dort draußen bilde, der sich so schnell bildet, dass die Scheibe zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch da ist. Also der Planet wächst sehr schnell, ich habe eine Gas- und Stoppscheibe, darin wächst der Planet sehr schnell. Und um ihn herum, er bewegt sich in dieser Scheibe. Und das führt dazu, dass der Planet und die Scheibe miteinander wechselwirken, die ziehen sich gegenseitig an. Ein bisschen kann man sich das vorstellen wie Reibung. Der Planet bewegt sich durch die Scheibe und er verliert langsam Energie. Er wird immer langsamer und was passiert dann? Er fängt an hineinzuspiralieren in Richtung Stern.
Weil er der Anziehungskraft der Sonne nicht mehr entgegensetzen kann?
Genau, weil er Energie verliert, dadurch, dass er sich durch diese Scheibe bewegen muss. Das macht einen Unterschied, als wenn die Scheibe spätestens die Scheibe weckt. So wie im Sonnensystem hier bewegen sich die Planeten.
Und die ISS muss ja die ganze Zeit befeuert werden, weil sie sonst durch die Atmosphäre nach oben gezogen wird.
Genau, das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Solange diese Scheibe noch da ist, erzeugt sie Reibung. Der Planet verliert Energie, er spiraliert rein. Und es hat sich sogar herausgestellt, dass das normal so passiert. In den meisten Simulationsrechnungen. Man macht viele, viele Rechnungen, weil man ja nicht weiß, wie die Startbedingungen sind. Also nimmt man alle möglichen Startbedingungen an und schaut, was passiert. Und in den meisten Fällen spiraliert der Planet hinein. Jetzt hat man folgendes Situation heute. Man hat also gar kein Problem mehr, damit diese heißen Gasriesen, wie man sie nennt, heiß, weil sie in so einem Armstern sind, zu erklären, warum die dort sind. Die sind hineingewandert. Was mir auch nicht ganz klar ist, warum sie nicht in den Stern einfach reinfallen. Warum hören die dann irgendwo auf? Und das zweite Problem ist natürlich, dass man jetzt erklären muss, warum im Sonnensystem nicht so eine große Wanderung von Jupiter und Saturn stattgefunden hat. Die haben sich zwar auch ein bisschen bewegt, aber sie sind nicht zur Sonne hingewandert. Sie sind nicht innerhalb der Merkobahn, sie sind ja immer noch da draußen.
Das kann aber sein, dass sie irgendwann mal weiter draußen waren und etwas reinmarschiert sind?
Sie haben sich ein bisschen bewegt, aber in unserem Fall ist die Bewegung von Jupiter und Saturn gegenseitig gerade so gewesen, dass sie verhindert wurde, dass sie in die Sonne fallen. Und so hat sich durch die Entdeckung von extrasolaren Planeten schon unser Bild auf die Planetenentstehung etwas erweitert und etwas verändert auch. Das heißt, Fälle, die in Simulationsrechnungen auch vorher vor der Entdeckung aufgetreten sind, die aber als, okay, das tritt ja nicht auf, das kann nicht sein, das sind Fehler der Rechnung sozusagen. Heute, wir sehen, nein, solche Fälle treten durchaus auf, die beobachten wir. Und so kann sich eben ein Planeten-System auch entwickeln. Aber damals, als 51 Pilgasos entdeckt wurde, 95, war das erst mal kaum vorstellbar. Das hat sich erst danach entwickelt, dass es sehr wohl zu simulieren geht, dass es auch gar nicht so schwer ist, das in den Rechnungen zu erzeugen oder nachzuvollziehen. Und heute ist diese Migration, wie man diesen Prozess nennt, dieses nach innen Wandern, ein akzeptierter Weg eines Planeten, eines Gasplaneten.
Das heißt, diese Entdeckung eines anderen Planeten oder dieser Blick in ein anderes Sonnensystem, der so mehr nur gezeigt hat als eben die Sterne, die man bisher eben wahrnehmen konnte, hat im Prinzip dazu beigetragen, das komplette Verständnis des Aufbaus von Sonnensystemen überhaupt erst mal wieder nach vorne zu bringen. Weil man einfach eine Voraussetzung, also eine Situation vorgefunden hat, die wir eben so hier einfach nicht haben.
Genau, genau. Und das zeigt sich in diesem Fall. Das heißt, eine der Richtungen, der Forschungsrichtungen, in die wir jetzt gehen, in dem Gebiet, ist erst mal möglichst viele auch Planetensysteme zu finden. Man hat heute auch sehr viele Planeten, einige hundert Planetensysteme gefunden. Also mehr als ein Planet pro Stern. Die meisten zwei Planeten pro Stern und dann bis hin zu sechs Planeten pro Stern. Davon möchte man mehr finden, um zu schauen, gibt es denn jetzt typische Planetensystemarchitekturen, nennen wir das. Also wie sind die aufgebaut? Ist es doch normal, was wir im Sonnensystem sehen? Innen sind Gesteinsplaneten, außen sind Gasplaneten. Sind diese heißen Jupiter die Ausnahme? Oder gibt es andere Strukturen, die normal sind? Zum Beispiel zeigt sich jetzt, dass kleine Sterne, also massearme Sterne, auch kleine Planeten haben. Massearme Sterne haben in der Regel keinen Gasriesen wie den Jupiter. Wahrscheinlich, weil die massearmen Sterne auch eine geringere Scheibenmasse haben, dann ist einfach weniger Material da. Aber ich gebe mich jetzt an Spekulation. Das sind alles Dinge, die wir untersuchen und bestätigen müssen. Sodass man eben mehr Planetensysteme schauen möchte und schauen möchte, was ist ein normales Planetensystem. Ein System wie unseres, was unsrem direkt, eine direkte Kopie wäre, haben wir bisher noch nicht gefunden. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass die Detektionsmethoden dafür noch nicht gut genug sind. Denn eine Erde um die Sonne ist im Moment gerade außerhalb und an der Grenze der Messgenauigkeit.
Also würde man jetzt von einem anderen Sonnensystem auf unseres blicken, wäre die Erde einfach zu nah an der Sonne?
Nein, das ist nicht das Problem. Vielleicht können wir mal kurz über die Methoden sprechen, wie man Planeten entdeckt, dann kann ich etwas erklären, warum die Erde so schwer zu entdecken ist.
Gerne.
Das Problem, extrasolare Planeten zu entdecken, liegt daran, dass sie einen Stern umkreisen, und zwar natürlich keine Planeten, aber sie umkreisen ihren Stern, und der Stern ist sehr hell. Die Sonne ist eine Million Mal heller als die Erde. Und Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn Sie eine Mücke oder eine Fliege aus drei Kilometer Entfernung um einen Leuchtturm sehen möchten, dann haben Sie ein Problem, weil der Leuchtturm ist einfach viel heller. Wir sehen die schwache Lichtquelle nicht. Das zweite Problem ist, dass das Planetensystem relativ nah am Stern ist. Sie müssen es also auch räumlich trennen können. Also die direkte Abbildung extrasolarer Planeten ist sehr schwierig. Sie hat in den letzten Jahren allerdings große Fortschritte gemacht, und es wird auch in den nächsten Jahrzehnten, zehn, zwanzig Jahren, dort große Fortschritte geben, mit weiterer Instrumentenentwicklung. Wir haben Abbildungen von extrasolaren Planetensystemen, wo man die Planeten als kleine Punkte neben ihrem Stern sieht. Das sind allerdings alles sehr junge Planetensysteme, wo es sich um große Gasriesen handelt, die sehr jung sind, die also selber noch kontrahieren, die dann im Infraroten, im thermischen Weldingbereich sehr hell sind und deswegen ein besseres Kontrastverhältnis haben zum Stern und die relativ weit noch von ihrem Stern weg sind. Das heißt, mit direkter Abbildung das, was man am liebsten möchte. Menschen möchten mal ein Bild haben, ein Foto machen. Das geht, aber es geht eben nur für eine bestimmte Art von Planetensystemen zur Zeit, nämlich die sehr, sehr jungen, mit großen Gasriesen, die relativ weit weg sind. Das ist spannend, klar, aber wir möchten natürlich, unser großes Ziel in diesem Gebiet ist natürlich, Planetensysteme wie unser Sonnensystem abbilden zu können oder sehen zu können. Von einer solchen Abbildung sind wir im Moment leider noch weit entfernt.
Aber es gibt sozusagen, von den anderen gibt es durchaus Abbildungen. Also es ist gelungen, richtig Bilder zu machen von Planeten.
Ja, wie gesagt, junge Gasriesen, relativ weit weg, aber ja, wir haben Bilder von Planeten und andere Sterne. Faszinierend, ja.
Wie weit sind die so weg? Wie weit ist überhaupt der erste, den man gefunden hat, entfernt?
Ja, diese Planetensysteme sind leider sehr, sehr weit weg von uns. Einige hundert bis tausend Lichtjahres in dieser Größenordnung. Viel zu weit weg, um hinzufliegen. Also das muss man vorausschicken. Science-Fiction bleibt Science-Fiction. Hinfliegen können wir nicht. Und das macht es auch gleich so schwierig, wenn wir darüber reden, von der Entdeckung wegkommen, zum nächsten Schritt nämlich erfahren wollen, was sind das für Planeten? Wir können eben nicht hinfliegen. Und viele Methoden, die wir im Sonnensystem haben, dort nicht anwenden.
Aber so jetzt sagen wir mal, in intergalaktischem Maßstab, sind das schon so unsere Nachbarn?
Das sind unsere nächsten Nachbarn.
Innerhalb der Milchstraße ist das jetzt nicht so auf der anderen Seite, sondern schon so um die Ecke.
Genau, also für Astronomen ist es die nächste Nachbarschaft. Nur, dass es eben die nächsten Nachbarn sehr weit, also für unsere Reisefähigkeiten sehr weit weg sind. Da gibt es noch was für zukünftige Generationen zu tun. Zu den Entdeckungsmethoden, also direkte Abbildung ist möglich, ja, aber beschränkt auf einen bestimmten Typus von Planeten zurzeit. Wenn ich Planeten entdecken will, die eher dem ähneln, wie wir sie hier im Sonnensystem haben und die vor allen Dingen nah am Stern sind, so nah wie unsere Planeten, muss man andere Methoden anwenden. Und dann ist man auf indirekte Methoden angewiesen. Die beiden erfolgreichsten Methoden sind die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode und die Transitmethode. Mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode wurde auch 51 Pegasus entdeckt. Und die Methode funktioniert so, dass man die Bewegung des Planeten um den Stern misst bzw. die Bewegung des Sterns und des Planeten um einander um ihren gemeinsamen Masseschwerpunkt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ein Planet einfach nur seinen Stern umkreist, sondern sie bewegen sich um ihren gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt. Und das heißt, auch der Stern bewegt sich. Natürlich nicht mit so großer Amplitude, aber er bewegt sich. Und er bewegt sich mit der gleichen Umlaufperiode, wie ihn der Planet umkreist. Wenn wir den Planeten sehen, wir leider nicht, aber bei Sternen haben wir ja das Glück, die senden Licht aus. Und dieses Licht hat Absorptionslinien, also Signaturen der Atomenmoleküle in der Sternenatmosphäre bei bestimmten Wellenlängen. Und wenn sich jetzt der Stern umkreist, also den gemeinsamen Masseschwerpunkt, wenn Sie den Stern anschauen, bewegt er sich immer mal auf Sie zu und mal von Ihnen weg. Er bewegt sich auf einer Kreisbaume, da hat er mal einen Teil des Wegs, geht auf Sie zu, ein Teil geht von Ihnen weg. Und da kommt hier der Doppler-Effekt hinein, den Sie vielleicht noch aus der Schulzeit kennen. Wenn ich ein Auto höre, das ein Signal aussende, dann verschieben sich die Wellenlängen, je nachdem, ob das Auto auf mich zufährt oder von mir wegfährt. Genau, das berühmte Tatütata oder der Rennwagen. Das passiert auch mit Licht. Die Lichtwellen machen das genauso. Und wenn ich dort Markierungen in den Lichtwellen habe, Absorptionslinien in der Sternenatmosphäre, dann kann ich diese Wellenlängenverschiebung sehr gut messen. Diese Wellenlängenverschiebung sagt mir jetzt, wann bewegt sich der Stern auf mich zu, wann bewegt er sich von mir weg. Ich kann das umrechnen in die Geschwindigkeit, mit der er sich auf mich zu und von mir weg bewegt. Und wenn ich diese Geschwindigkeit messe über die Zeit, dann hat man ein periodisches Signal. Es geht mal auf mich zu, mal von mir weg, dann kommt er wieder auf mich zu.
Wir reden hier von extrem geringen Schwankungen. Wenn man jetzt 1000 Lichtjahre entfernt ist und der Stern bewegt sich dann, keine Ahnung, mit einigen Tausende Kilometer auf einen zu, das ist sozusagen die Differenz, die man da rausrechnen muss. Wie genau muss man dann der Stelle diese Rotverschiebung berechnen, um überhaupt so etwas messen zu können?
Also das Signal ist sehr klein. Es bewegt sich im Bereich von einigen Metern pro Sekunde. Und wenn ich die Erde um eine Sonne messen, das Signal, was die Erde erzeugen würde, wäre im Bereich von 10 Zentimetern pro Sekunde. Ein Jupiter würde ein Meter pro Sekunde. Wenn Sie mal langsam gehen, vor sich hingehen und zählen, so 22, 23, damit wir jemals einen Schritt machen, dann sehen Sie, wie langsam das ist. Und die Erde wäre 10 Zentimeter pro Sekunde, sehr langsam. Das ist die Messgrenze. Das kann man heute zum Suchen noch nicht erreichen. Aber es geht. Das geht vor allen Dingen deswegen, weil der Stern sehr viele, hunderte von Tausenden von Absorptionslinien enthält und man die gut korrelieren kann, sodass man selbst kleinste Verschiebungen nachweisen kann.
Mit welchen Messinstrumenten kann man das überhaupt messen?
Das macht man mit Teleskopen von der 2 bis 8, 10 oder 10 Meter Spiegelgröße und einem sehr, sehr stabilen, hochauflösenden Spektrografen. Der erste Planet 51 Pegasus wurde entdeckt in Südfrankreich an einem 2-Meter-Teleskop, wo man so einen hochauflösenden Spektrografen hat. Damals war das natürlich eine relativ, wie soll ich sagen, exotische Messung, sodass man dort an den Großteleskopen für so etwas keine Zeit bekommt. Das muss man schon an kleineren machen, wo man auch mal etwas ausprobieren kann. Wenn Sie zu einer Erde um eine Sonne gehen, dann muss man an 8, 10 Meter Teleskope gehen oder noch größere, die ESO und die USA, planen jeweils 30, 40 Meter große Spiegel, die dann in 10 Jahren in Betrieb gehen sollen. So etwas macht man an großen Teleskopen vom Boden. Nicht vom Weltraum aus, einmal weil es vom Boden aus geht. Und zweitens, weil man diese Hochauflösungsspektrografen, das sind sehr komplexe Instrumente, die können Sie nicht mal so eben auf den Satelliten tun. Das passiert vom Erdboden aus. Ja, mit dieser Messung, mit der Messung des Radialgeschwindigkeitsignals kann man das dritte Keplerische Gesetz nehmen, von Johannes Kepler entwickelt, dass das, der das sagt, dass das Quadrat der Umlaufzeiten gleich den Abstand des Planeten um den Stern hoch drei ist. Das heißt, man kriegt den Abstand des Planeten. Sie kriegen aus dieser Messung also die Umlaufperiode des Planeten, seinen Abstand vom Stern. Und sie bekommen eine untere Grenze für die Masse. Und das ist ja immerhin schon mal ganz gar nicht so schlecht.
Sozusagen dem Licht des Sterns sieht man an, dass er von einem anderen Planeten umlaufen wird, weil dieser Planet an ihm reißt.
Genau, weil er an ihm reißt und der Stern sich dadurch auf einer Bahn bewegt, einer Kreisbahn, wenn der Planet eine Kreisbahn hat.
Aber es reißt ja unter Umständen noch sehr viel mehr als nur ein Planet an diesem Stern.
Noch?
Naja, andere Planeten, also weitere Planeten, eine ganze Kette an Planeten. Wie kann man die denn dann auseinanderhalten? Das heißt, man hat so ein etwas komplexeres Muster, wo man sieht, das kann so jetzt nicht ein einzelner sein, sondern asymmetrisch kommen dann sozusagen einfach auch noch andere Bahnen mit rein, die man dann wiederum mathematisch auseinanderrechnen muss.
Genau, also wenn Sie sagen, wenn wir jetzt einen Planeten, einen Planeten nur haben und der bewegt sich auf einer Kreisbahn, dann ist das Signal die Änderung der Geschwindigkeit über die Zeit eine einfache Sinuskurve. Dann können Sie da eine Sinuskurve anpassen als Signal, Sie ziehen das ab und dann müsste ja nichts mehr übrig bleiben. Und wenn Sie dann sehen, da ist aber noch ein Signal dabei, dann ist da noch ein zweiter Planet. Und so kann man sukzessive sehen, wie viele Planeten in diesem System ist.
Mit einer einzigen Messung.
Die aber konstant durchgeführt werden muss über mindestens den Zeitraum des Umlaufs aller Planeten, die man da rausrechnen muss. Das kann also auch Jahre dauern.
Das kann auch Jahre dauern, das ist genau der Punkt. Also den 51 Pegasus mit einer Umlaufperiode von vier Tagen, da können Sie sich vorstellen, dass man in einer Beobachtungs-Saison über ein halbes Jahr, solange das Objekt sichtbar ist, eine Menge Daten zusammen akkumulieren kann. Wenn ich eine Erde um eine Sonne messen will, dann muss ich sie halt ein Jahr lang beobachten. Wenn ich jetzt nicht gerade an den Polen bin, wo mein Stern das ganze Jahr sichtbar ist, sondern ein Stern fällt, jetzt haben wir ja gerade die Wintersternbilder oben, im Sommer sehen wir die nicht mehr. Das heißt, typischerweise sehen Sie einen Teil vom Himmel ein halbes Jahr. Das heißt, Sie kriegen dann immer nur die Hälfte. Und die andere Hälfte des Signals kriegen Sie nicht. Müssen Sie sehr lange warten, bis Sie einen ganzen Umlauf eines Planeten abgedeckt haben. Das ist halt eines der Probleme bei dieser Methode, bei den meisten Methoden, dass weit entfernte Planeten sehr schwer zu entdecken sind. Da haben wir schon einen Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, ein System wie unseres, wie das Sonnensystem, ist noch nicht völlig im Bereich dessen, was wir beobachten können. Also was man jetzt beobachtet hat, sind zum Beispiel Jupiter, die auch auf einer Bahn sind wie unser Jupiter. 5 Jahre Umlaufperiode ist kein Problem. Es geht ein bisschen weiter hinaus, bis 10 Jahre jetzt. Aber das ganze Forschungsgebiet gibt es erst 20 Jahre. Sie können sich also denken, bis man das Signal von einem Pluto hat.
Da muss man noch ein paar Jahrhunderte drauf gehen.
Da muss man noch ein bisschen warten. Aber Geduld gehört bei der Astronomie und in der Weltraumforschung ja mit dazu.
Die Pluto-Nachrichten der letzten Wochen waren ja auch sehr reichhaltig. Da konnte man ja im Prinzip auch dieses Zusammenspiel von zwei Himmelskörpern schön sehen. Pluto und sein Planet. Im Anflug hat ja New Horizons schon sehr schöne Bilder geliefert, wie eben Pluto und sein Mond wunderbar umeinander tanzen. Und im Prinzip genau dieses Tanzbild mit dieser Verschiebung der Bahnen wunderbar sichtbar war, was wir jetzt hier gerade beschreiben zur Beobachtung Ferner Planeten.
Die zweite Methode, mit der man heute Planeten findet, also wie gesagt die beiden Hauptmethoden, die zweite ist die Transit-Methode. Die Transit-Methode funktioniert etwas anders, ist auch eine indirekte Methode. Aber während man bei der Radialgeschwindigkeit den Dopplereffekt misst durch Spektroskopie, ist die Transit-Methode eine fotometrische Messung. Das heißt, man misst die Helligkeit des Sterns. Und im Idealfall ist der Stern konstant hell. Wir wissen heute, dass es leider nicht so ist, aber im Idealfall ist der Stern konstant hell. Und wenn ich jetzt auf ein Planeten-System von der Seite draufschaue, nehme ich so, dass der Planet auf seiner Bahn immer wieder durch die Sichtlinie zieht, die ich zum Planeten habe. Also ich schaue mir den Stern die ganze Zeit an und wenn die Planetenbahn gerade zufällig so orientiert ist, dass ich sie von der Seite sehe, dann zieht ja immer wieder der Planet vor dem Stern vorbei. Dann geht er wieder rum, dann kommt er wieder vorbei.
Aber das ist ein bisschen Glück, weil das muss ja im Prinzip aus unserer Sichtposition heraus eben genauso eine Okkultation dann auch vorliegen.
Genau. Bei einem heißen Jupiter, so wie 51 Pegasus, liegt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, so ein Planetensystem zu finden bei 10%. Also 10% aller Sterne, die ich mir anschaue, hätte ich die Chance das System gerade so zu schauen, so zu sehen, dass ich von der Seite drauf schaue. Bei der Erde um die Sonne liegt die Wahrscheinlichkeit unter 1%. Dann können Sie sich schon ausrechnen, wie viele Sterne Sie anschauen müssen, um welche dabei zu haben, bei denen Sie gerade zufällig von der Seite rausschauen. Ich vergleiche das immer mit der Lotterie. Und so sind auch die Transit-Suchprojekte angelegt. Wenn ich Planeten mit der Transit-Methode suche, muss ich möglichst viele Sterne anschauen. Und je mehr Sterne ich anschaue, desto höher ist meine Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und es ist wie in einer Lotterie, wenn Sie heute alle Lose kaufen für die Ziehung am Samstag, dann haben Sie mit Sicherheit gewonnen. Wenn Sie 50 Prozent der Lose kaufen, dann haben Sie immer noch eine gute Chance. Und so funktioniert das halt mit der Transit-Methode auch. Man versucht, möglichst viele Sterne zu beobachten, um die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Entdeckung hochzubringen. Es macht keinen Sinn, nur einen Stern anzuschauen. Bei der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode schaut man einen Stern nach dem anderen an. Weil die Begrenzung natürlich nicht so groß ist. Wenn das System gerade so ist, dass die Bahn senkrecht zu meiner Blickrichtung ist, dann habe ich keine Radial- und Geschwindigkeitsauslenkung. Aber alle anderen erzeugen mir ein Signal. Das heißt, die Einschränkung ist viel geringer. Bei der Transitmethode habe ich wirklich eine große Einschränkung durch diese Geometrie. Man nennt es geometrische Wahrscheinlichkeit, diese eben sehr sehr kleine.
Aber ist es durchaus auch eine erfolgreiche Methode?
Es ist im Moment die erfolgreichste Methode. Und zwar die Messung ist dann relativ einfach vom Prinzip her. Das Messprinzip ist immer einfach in der Praxis, es ist dann etwas anderes. Aber das Messprinzip funktioniert dann so, wenn der Planet durch den Stern läuft, dann dunkelt er ja einen Teil der Oberfläche des Sterns ab. Das heißt, der Stern, das Sternlicht wird ein bisschen dunkler. Und die Größe der Abnahme ist proportional zur Größe des Planeten. Es ist klar, wenn ich einen großen Planeten habe, der vor einem Stern steht, dunkelt er mehr Sternoberfläche ab. Ich kriege also weniger Licht, als wenn ich nur einen kleinen Planeten habe, der vor dem Stern steht. Das heißt, ich bekomme damit durch dieses Signal nicht nur die Entdeckung, sondern ich bekomme auch die Größe des Planeten.
Weil?
Weil die Abdunkelung des Sternlichts proportional ist zur Größe des Planeten.
Aber hat man bei der Beobachtung vom Boden aus nicht ohnehin das Problem, dass quasi das beobachtete Licht durch unsere Atmosphäre permanent verdunkelt, nicht ein Systematmaktor?
Sie haben bei der Messung zwei Probleme. Einmal der Faktor der Erdatmosphäre, wenn man vom Boden misst. Und der zweite Faktor ist die Variabilität des Sterns. Von der Erde kann man heute mit dieser Transit-Methode problemlos Jupiter-große Planeten entdecken. Man kommt runter auf Neptun-große und wir selbst sind zusammen mit Schweizer und britischen Kollegen gerade dabei in Chile auf dem Gelände der Europäischen Südsternwarte. Das NGTS, das Next Generation Transit Survey, aufzubauen. Das sind dann 12 Teleskope mit einem 20 cm Spiegel, die mit der Transit-Methode nach Planeten suchen sollen. Und wir wollen das Limit vom Boden pushen bis zu der Grenze, wo es nicht mehr weitergeht. Das sind dann Mini-Neptune Super-Erden. Also in dem Bereich zwischen Erde und Neptune. Um wirklich dann an das Machbare, was vom Boden machbar ist, zu gehen.
Also Bereich im Sinne von Planetengröße.
Ja, und wenn man noch kleinere Planeten entdecken will, mit der Transit-Methode, dann muss man ins Weltall gehen. Zum Glück geht das relativ einfach, weil die Messung selbst eben Fotometrie ist. Das heißt, ich messe die Helligkeit des Sterns über die Zeit. Das bedeutet, ich brauche einfach eine Kamera, ich brauche ein Teleskop und ich brauche einen Detektor, aber ich brauche keinen komplexen Spektrografen oder so etwas. Das heißt, sowas kann man sehr kompakt bauen und auf dem Satelliten unterbringen. Und die erste Satellitenmission, die das gemacht hat, war die Mission Corot. Corot steht für Corotation and Transits. Das war eine Mission der CNES, der französischen Weltraumagentur, also eine nationale Mission, die allerdings internationale Beteiligungen hatte, unter anderem auch aus Deutschland. Wir am DLR in Berlin haben die Onboardsoftware geschrieben, also die Prozessierungssoftware der Daten auf dem Satelliten. Und wir haben Daten ausgewertet, wir haben die Datendetektionen und die Bestimmung der Planetenparameter aus den Daten koordiniert. Und Coro ist gestartet 2006, hat gearbeitet bis 2013. Dann war leider ein Impact und beide Bordcomputer waren kaputt. Nach zwei Jahren war schon der erste Kanal ausgefallen und dann doch 2013.
Also Impact ist also irgendwas eingeschlagen?
Irgendwas, irgendein hochenergetisches Strahlungteilchen. Irgendetwas, muss sagen, dass Coro allerdings seine nominelle Laufzeit dort schon beendet hatte. Es hatte sogar schon eine Verlängerung. Ja, eine weitere Verlängerung haben wir dann leider nicht mehr geschafft.
Aber war bis dahin auch recht erfolgreich.
War bis dahin sehr, sehr erfolgreich. Das große Highlight der Coro-Mission war die Entdeckung des ersten Gesteinsplaneten außerhalb des Sonnensystems. Und zwar des ersten Gesteinsplaneten, so man wirklich sicher ist, dass es ein Gesteinsplanet ist. Denn Sie müssen sich fragen, ich habe eine Methode, die gibt mir die Masse, ich habe eine Methode, die gibt mir den Radius. Aber es kann ja auch, es kann alles Mögliche sein. Also es wacht mir noch lange nicht, dass ich wirklich einen Planeten habe und welche Dichte der hat und welche Art von Planet das ist. Um das zu wissen, brauche ich beides, Radius und Masse. Und ich brauche auch einfach bei so einem kleinen Planeten mit entsprechenden Unsicherheiten im Signal die Bestätigung von zwei unabhängigen Methoden. Und das war mit Kuro möglich. Kuro hat durch Transits einen gesteinsgroßen Planeten entdeckt. 1,7 Mal so groß wie die Erde, 7 Mal so schwer. Auf einer Umlaufbahn, und das war wieder sehr überraschend, von 20 Stunden, also unter einem Tag. Ein Jahr entspricht weniger als einem Tag hier bei uns. Ist aber ein sonnenähnlicher Stern. Das war wieder noch mal ein Schritt hin zu unglaublichen Parametern, die man nicht erwartet hat bei extrasolaren Planeten. Das betrifft eigentlich alles, was man angeschaut hat bisher, war immer eine Überraschung. Kuro, also extrem nah am Stern, extrem heiß, um es gleich zu sagen, obwohl es ein gesteinsplanet ist, eben nicht bewohnbar, weil viel zu heiß, 1000 Grad auf der Tagseite. Trotzdem ein Meilenstein in der Entdeckungsgeschichte, weil der erste gesicherte Gesteinsplanet ist.
Warum war man sich jetzt so sicher, dass es ein Gesteinsplanet ist?
Weil wir die Transit-Methode haben, den Radius vom Satelliten, und danach wurde das größte bodengebundene Nachfolgebeobachtungsprogramm durchgeführt, was jemals für einen Planeten durchgeführt wurde, mit Großteleskopen, die durch die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode dann die Massen bestimmt haben.
Also das hat Kuro nicht selber gemacht, sondern Kuro war sozusagen nur wiegbereiter durch die...
Nee, umgekehrt. Also die Entdeckung kam durch den Kuro-Satelliten durch die Transit-Methode. Damit hat man die Umlaufperiode, den Abstand und die Größe des Planeten.
Und dann wurde sozusagen unten abgearbeitet.
Und dann sucht man, genau, dann schaut man vom Boden, sehe ich das auch, das Signal mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode. Also ich bestätige die Messung des Satelliten. Und die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode gibt mir dann noch die Masse. Und damit habe ich Radius und Masse. Dann stellt sich raus, die Dichte entspricht etwa der Dichte der Erde. Und damit weiß ich, ich habe hier wirklich einen Gesteinsplaneten vor mir. Kurz danach hat dann die amerikanische Kepler-Mission, die 2009 gestartet war, die ebenfalls mit der gleichen Messmethode misst, ebenfalls einen Gesteinsplaneten entdeckt, Kepler-10b, sodass es zwei Planeten gibt. Beide wurden mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode nachbeobachtet. Und beide haben interessanterweise dann in der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode noch zwei weitere Planeten gezeigt, die aber keine Transits machen.
Die also nicht unbedingt auf derselben Ebene lagen.
Die nicht an der gleichen Ebene lagen.
So ein bisschen wie der Pluto in unserem Sonnensystem, auch so etwas schräg ist.
Wo die Ebene ein bisschen gekippt ist, sodass die äußeren Planeten dann eben gerade nicht mehr am Stern vorbeiziehen. Dann haben wir dann innerhalb von wenigen Jahren zwei Planeten gehabt, Gesteinsplaneten. Das heißt, heute können wir sagen, ja, es gibt Gesteinsplaneten außerhalb des Sonnensystems. Beide waren natürlich zu heiß. Oder sind zu heiß, um bewohnbar zu sein. Aber es zeigt die Möglichkeiten, die Messmöglichkeiten der Transit-Methode, solche kleinen Planeten zu entdecken. Und das Transit-Signal hängt im Prinzip nicht vom Abstand ab. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, es zu sehen, hängt vom Abstand ab. Aber das Signal selber hängt nur von der Größe des Planeten ab. Also wenn er denn vorbeiläuft, dann ist das Messsignal genauso groß, ob er nah dran ist oder weiter weg. Das heißt, die Transit-Methode ist eine sehr gute Methode, um kleine Planeten zu entdecken. Das heißt, man hat jetzt zunächst zwei weitere Satellitenmissionen, die Kepler nachfolgen. Oder ich sollte vielleicht erstmal über Kepler reden. Kepler hat auch 2013 aufgehört zu arbeiten. 2013 war ein schwarzes Jahr für uns. Alle Lichter ausgegangen. Genau, alle Lichter ausgegangen. Auch Kepler hatte Probleme mit den Reaction Wheels, den Stabilisierungsrädern des Satelliten. Kepler hat vier an Bord, also einen in Reserve, aber es waren dann zwei ausgefallen.
Dann kann der Satellit seine Position nicht mehr zuverlässig halten.
Dann kann der Satellit seine Position nicht mehr so zuverlässig halten. Ich muss auch sagen, auch Kepler hat seine Laufzeit mit Bravour absorbiert. Auch das ist in der verlängerten Zeit passiert. Dann muss man sagen, okay, so ist es halt. Aber die Ingenieure der NASA sind sehr clever gewesen und haben jetzt eine Möglichkeit gefunden, mit Kepler in Bildfelder in der Ekliptik zu schauen, wo sie den Satelliten für 80 Tage stabil halten können. Das heißt, dass sie die Ausrichtung der Bildfelder so wählen, dass sie mit zwei Gerasionsrädern die Taumelbewegung des Satelliten noch ausgleichen können, für 80 Tage. Vorher hat Kepler 4 Jahre auf ein Bildfeld geschaut. Das Ziel von Kepler war eher, um eine Sonne zu finden. Kepler hat 4 Jahre auf ein Bildfeld geschaut, weil wenn sie mit der Transitmethode messen, sie detektieren einen Transit, einer ist keine, sie detektieren einen zweiten Transit, dann haben sie schon mal die Periode. Dann brauchen sie eine dritte Messung, um es zu bestätigen. Also 3 wären die minimale Zahl der Transits, die man haben möchte. Und 4, und eigentlich brauchen sie mehr, weil die Messung ist natürlich verrauscht und das ist nicht so einfach.
Also würde man jetzt genau die Erde damit beobachten, dann würde man sagen, okay, 4 Umdrehungen um die Sonne und dann haben wir einen Plan.
Genau. Um es gleich zu sagen, eine Erde um die Sonne hat Kepler nicht gefunden. Aber Kepler hat uns eine unglaubliche Zahl von Planeten Statistik gegeben, mehrere, viele hundert Planeten entdeckt. Es ist komplett, es hat einen guten Service bis 80 Tage gemacht und wir haben zumindest eine Idee der Anzahl von terrestrischen Planeten bei großen Abständen. Wobei diese Zahl ist sehr umstritten. Aber sie liegt etwa zwischen 20, 30 bis 30 Prozent, gibt das Kepler-Team an. Es ist sehr umstritten. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, es liegt bei 10 Prozent. Es gibt andere, die sagen, es liegt bei 60, 70, 80 Prozent. Das ist eine sehr offene Zahl. Aber immerhin haben wir durch diese 4 Jahre im Umlauf, 4 Jahre Kepler-Daten eine Idee. Jetzt kann Kepler nur noch 80 Tage auf ein Bildfeld schauen. Damit liegt es mehr in der Liga von Kuro. Kuro hat 150 Tage auf ein Bildfeld geschaut. Das heißt, man kann nur noch kurz periodische Planeten entdecken. Wenn sie 80 Tage haben, ungefähr 3 Monate, und sie wollen 3 Transits haben, dann sind sie halt bei 3 Monaten Umlaufperiode.
Aber besser als nichts. Immerhin kann man das Ding noch mal zu was benutzen.
Genau, Sie sehen Planeten bis zur Merkulbahn. Und das, was wir vorhin diskutiert haben, Statistik von Planetenarchitekturen, von Systematiken, von weiteren Erkunden dieser heißen Planeten, ist K2, wie die Mission jetzt heißt, natürlich wunderbar.
Sind Kuro und Kepler jetzt von der Instrumentierung her identisch?
Ähnlich. Kuro hatte noch ein zweites Team. Kuro war etwas besonders, weil Kuro hat sich die Fokalebene der Kamera geteilt mit einem weiteren wissenschaftlichen Ziel, nämlich der Astro-Seismologie. Die Astro-Seismologie misst, wie das Wort Seismologie vielleicht schon sagt, in dem Fall Sonnenbeben, also die Eigenschwingungen der Sonne. Das ist so ein Gasball, der schwingt halt, und die Eigenschwingungen hängen ab von dem Material, der dichte Struktur und der inneren Struktur des Sterns. Was man damit messen kann und bestimmen kann, sind sehr genau die Sternparameter. Denn ich habe Ihnen ein bisschen etwas verschwiegen bei den Entdeck, bei den Methoden. Ich habe gesagt, man kann die Massen und die Radien der Planeten bestimmen, und das stimmt auch. Es stimmt aber nur, wenn ich annehme, dass ich die Sternparameter auch kenne.
Was sind die Sternparameter?
Die Sternmassen und die Sternradien. Und wenn Sie sich vorstellen, dass Sie jetzt zu sehr kleinen Planeten gehen wollen, wie die Erde, dann müssen Sie auch z.B. den Radius des Sterns entsprechend gut kennen. Und Sie müssen die Masse des Sterns genug kennen. Und wenn ich über die Planeten noch mehr lernen möchte, z.B. wie entwickeln sich Planeten über die Zeit- oder Planetensysteme, möchte ich auch das Alter des Planetensystems kennen. Das Alter der Planeten kann ich aber auf die Entfernung nicht bestimmen. Ich kann ja keine Isotopenanalysen machen oder so etwas, sondern ich kann aber das Alter der Sterns bestimmen. Und die genaueste Methode, um Alter von Sternen zu bestimmen, ist die Astroseismologie. Und dieses ganze Forschungsgebiet, die Astroseismologie, ist mit Choro, hat durch Choro einen sehr großen Aufschwung genommen, weil sich Choro die Fokal-Ebene eben geteilt hat. Man hat wirklich den Detektor geteilt, die eine Hälfte haben, in der einen Hälfte wurde nach Sternen, nach Planeten gesucht, in der anderen Hälfte hat man helle Sterne angeschaut für Astroseismologie. Es gab in dem Feld für die Planetensuche nur ganz wenige Sterne, die hell genug waren, um Astroseismologie zu machen. Aber man hat etwas gelernt. Man hat das dann so gut man konnte, auch bei den Kepler-Daten und jetzt bei den K2-Daten angewandt, man hat nämlich gelernt, ich muss nicht nur die Planeten detektieren und das Signal der Planeten genau genug messen, ich muss auch die Sternparameter genauer bestimmen, als es bisher nötig war.
Um sie überhaupt in Relation setzen zu können, eine Aussage treffen zu können.
Genau, um überhaupt eine sichere Aussage über den Planeten treffen zu können. Es ist heute so, dass die Messgenauigkeit der Planeten nicht mehr limitiert ist durch das Instrument. Es sei denn, ich rede über das Extrem der Erde um die Sonne, aber für die meisten andere ist es nicht mehr durch dieses Instrument limitiert, sondern es ist limitiert durch das Wissen über den Stern. Sie haben eine Erde mit 6400 Kilometer Radius. Wenn ich da eine 10% Ungenauigkeit akzeptieren kann, bin ich bei einigen 100 Kilometern Radius. Wenn Sie sich jetzt die Sonne vorschauen, die um zwei Größen und drei Größenordnungen größer ist, und ich will dort den Radius auch auf 10% haben, ist das wesentlich schwieriger. Das heißt, es hat sich auch durch die Entdeckung extrasolarer Planeten, das ist auch ganz interessant, hat auch das Gebiet der Stellaren Astrophysik wieder einen Aufschwung genommen, denn für die Stellaren Physiker, so genau brauchten die das für ihre Sachen eigentlich gar nicht zu wissen, das hat sie nicht so interessiert.
Die waren zufrieden, wenn sie etwa die Zusammensetzung und das Alter damit bestimmen.
Ja, die waren zufrieden mit 20-30%, so etwas.
Auch in Bezug auf das Alter.
Auf das Alter waren sie nicht zufrieden, aber sie hatten keine Möglichkeit, es besser zu machen.
Aber was hat das jetzt konkret verbessert? Also dadurch, dass man sich sozusagen diese Schwingung anschaut, könnte man, also was sagen die Schwingungen über das Alter aus? Schwingt die immer mehr oder immer weniger?
Ne, es ändert sich, dass man, also ein Stern sendet ja Licht aus, weil er Energie erzeugt. Und die Energie erzeugt er in seinem Inneren durch Kernfusion. Kernfusion bedeutet, dass man Wasserstoffkerne in Heliumkerne umwandelt, in schwerere Kerne. Das heißt, in so einem Stern finden diese Kernfusionsprozesse statt und damit ändert sich aber die Dichte und die Zusammensetzung der Sterne über die Zeit. Und die Eigenschwingungen von einem Gasball, die hängen davon ab, welche Dichte er hat, welche Dichte Verteilung er hat. Das heißt, die Eigenschwingungen ändern sich dadurch. Es gibt die Astrosysemologie wie bei den Erdbeben. Da gibt es Beben, die an der Oberfläche langlaufen und Wellen, die an der Oberfläche langlaufen. Und es gibt Wellen, die durch den Erdkern durchgehen oder tief in die Erde hineingehen. Und genauso gibt es bei den Sternen Wellen, die an der Oberfläche laufen und Wellen, die durch das Innere der Sterne hindurchgehen und die uns Auskunft darüber geben, was in dem Inneren der Sterne, welche Bedingungen dort herrschen.
Also diese typische Wechselwirkung in einem Stern, das auf der einen Seite durch diese schiere Masse, durch die Gravitation alles nach innen gezogen wird, aber auf der anderen Seite durch die Kernfusion dieser Druck nach außen erzeugt wird und dadurch der Stern sich stabil hält, das ist etwas, was unter anderem zu diesen Schwingungen beiträgt. Und wenn man sich das halt anschaut, dann weiß man, wie es dem Stern geht.
Genau, man weiß, was man im Prinzip weiß, indirekt ist, wie viel von dem Wasserstoff ist schon in Helium und in schwere Elemente umgewandelt. Und das sagt was über das Alter aus. Genau. Und das ist jetzt eine Methode, die angestoßen durch Kuro, durch Kepler, durch die Missionen, wo man das erste Mal Lichtkurven über lange Zeit hatte, Astroseismologie, durch Photometrie sehr gut machen konnte. Und ein Interesse hat von den Exoplanetenforschern, von uns, die sagen, gebt uns bitte diese Sternparameter, die Masse, die Radien des Sterns, das Alter des Sterns, so genau wie ihr könnt, nimmt das einen sehr großen Aufschwung und wird auch dazu führen, dass die Kollegen, die sich zum Beispiel mit der Milchstraße beschäftigen, die immer darüber hadern, dass sie die Alter der Sterne nicht genug kennen, jetzt plötzlich Informationen kriegen, die ihnen auch sehr nützlich sein können.
Das heißt, die Suche nach Planeten hat eigentlich vor allem auch erstmal das Verständnis über die Sterne, die sie umkreisen, verbessert, weil es einfach die Voraussetzung dafür ist, erfolgreich auf Planeten-Suche gehen zu können.
Es gibt plötzlich einen Schub in ein Forschungsgebiet hinein, was in den 60er-, 70er-Jahren ein sehr großer Boom war, aber seitdem so ein bisschen, ja, man hatte das eigentlich gedacht, das ist verstanden, und jetzt kommt jemand und sagt, wir brauchen das aber noch viel, viel genauer, als ihr das verstanden habt. Und so gibt es einen Schub hinein in andere Forschungsgebiete jetzt, die durch die Exoplaneten getriggert wurden. Ich finde das sehr, sehr spannend. Es beschränkt sich nicht nur auf die Planetenphysiker, sondern es geht jetzt hinaus bis in die Erforschung der Milchstraße hinein.
Wir hatten ja vorhin kurz über die Unterschiede noch gesprochen oder die Weiterentwicklung, die Kepler gegenüber Corot bedeutet hat. Also auf der einen Seite ist die längere Beobachtungszeit, eben diese vier Jahre gegenüber den 150 Tagen von Corot, aber ist diese Astrosaismologie an der Stelle auch genauso ein Thema gewesen zwangsläufig?
Ja, bei Kepler gab es auch viel astrosaismologische Untersuchungen, aber eben nicht in dem Umfang, wie man es gerne hätte. Der Grund liegt daran, dass Corot und Kepler in einer Zeit gemacht wurden, designt und gebaut wurden, als man gedacht hat, es reicht nur Transit zu haben. Man hat dann durch die Planeten, für die man Photometrie, transitsgemäß Neutradien hatte und Follow-up machen konnte, Nachfolgebeobachtung verboten machen konnte und Massen hatte, gemerkt, dass es nicht reicht. Sondern Planeten sind viel, viel, viel fältiger, als wir uns jemals haben vorstellen können. Man hat ganz neue Typen von Planeten gefunden. Ich hatte sie ja schon ein bisschen erwähnt, die sogenannten Supererden, die Mini-Neptune. Was man damit meint, ist, dass es Planeten gibt in einem großen Bereich und in einem Massenbereich, wie er in unserem Sonnensystem nicht auftritt. In unserem Sonnensystem haben wir sehr schöne Schubladendenken. Wir haben die Merco Venus Erde Mars. Die bestehen alle aus Gestein. Die haben kaum eine Atmosphäre. Auch die Erde ist uns sehr wichtig, aber gemessen an der Gesamterde ist es sehr klein. Die sind alle klein, die sind alle massearm. Und sie bestehen aus Gestein und sie sind innen. Und die Gasplaneten sind alle groß und sehr schwer und bestehen aus Wasserstoff mit Helium und Spurenstoffen. Zwei Schubladen. Oder wenn sie es noch aufteilen wollen, können sie es in drei Schubladen aufteilen, nämlich die beiden Gasriesen, Jupiter, Saturn und die Eisplaneten Uranus, Neptun. So, drei Schubladen kannte man. Und jetzt kommen Exoplaneten. Und da gibt es Planeten, die sind anderthalbmal so schwer wie die Erde, wo sie sagen würden, naja, bisschen größere Erde, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Und dann gehen sie hin und messen die Masse. Und mit Masse und Radius können sie die Dichte bestimmen. Und dann haben sie eine Dichte, die liegt unter einem Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter. Das kann kein fester Planet sein. Das kann nur gehen, wenn ich einen Kern habe aus Gestein und eine sehr große Wasserstoffhülle, die den Planeten größer macht, als er eigentlich ist im Transit. Die Erde hat so eine Dichte von 5,55 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter. Genau. 1 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter hat das Wassereis in ihrem Glas. Und wenn sie da runtergehen, dann reden wir über Gasplaneten. Das heißt, die Dichte ist ein erstes Maß, ein erster Anhaltspunkt darüber, ob ich es mit einem Gesteinsplaneten zu tun habe oder mit einem Gasplaneten. Wenn ich also Dichten habe im Bereich von 3 bis 5,6 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter, habe ich es mit Gestein, Gestein-Eisenkörpern zu tun. Wenn ich Dichten habe um 1 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter oder darunter, dann habe ich vielleicht ein Gesteinskern, aber da drum herum muss ich eine Gashülle aus Wasserstoff haben. Bei uns im Sonnensystem sind die ja so schön sortiert. Alle die mit den Gashüllen, die sind auch groß und schwer. Jetzt haben wir plötzlich welche entdeckt, die haben Massen, die sind also nicht wenig schwerer als die Erde, aber viel, viel größer. Das heißt, sie haben eine ganz ausgedehnte Wasserstoffhülle. Minigasplaneten. Oder wie wir sie auch nennen, Mini-Neptune. Einfach in Anlehnung an einen.
Die schon ein Herz aus Stein haben, aber wo einfach noch sehr viel mehr Atmosphäre ist.
Sehr viel mehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr Atmosphäre ist. Und umgekehrt, auch in der Größe. Sie haben Planeten, die einmal so groß sind wie die Erde, aber ein Vielfaches an Masse haben. Das heißt, wir finden eine Diversität in den Planeten, wie wir sie im Sonnensystem nicht kennen. Und wir haben gelernt, es ist nicht so einfach, einen wirklichen Gesteinsplaneten, mit einer Dichte wie die Erde, wirklich Gestein, zu unterscheiden von so einem Minigas-Planeten. Und das macht es so schwierig. Das hat früher niemand gedacht. Ich erinnere mich noch an Kuro in Ende der 2000er. Als es große Diskussionen gab, brauchen wir denn überhaupt diese Nachfolgemessungen, um die Massen zu bestimmen? Es reicht doch, wenn wir wissen, dass der nur ein bisschen größer als die Erde ist. Dann weiß ich doch schon, das ist ein Gesteinsplanet. So hat man früher gedacht. Das waren wirklich harte Diskussionen. Weil es ist ja sehr aufwendig, diese Nachfolgebeobachtung zu machen und kostet und so weiter. Heute zweifelt das keiner an, weil wir wissen, einem einen Parameter alleine reicht nicht. Wir brauchen beide. Wir müssen die Dichten bestimmen, um zumindest erstmal einen Anhaltspunkt zu haben. Das Problem, das wissen wir jetzt. Das haben wir gelernt aus Kuro, das haben wir gelernt aus Kepler. Für die Planeten, wo das möglich war. Leider ist es aber für die große Zahl der Planeten, die entdeckt wurden, mit Keplern nicht möglich. Warum nicht? Weil die Sterne zu lichtschwach sind. Ich kann vor allen Dingen die Nachfolgemessung vom Boden, die spektroskopische Messung nur bei hellen Objekten machen. Von der Erde aus machen, weil die passieren vom Erdboden aus. Ich mache Spektroskopie damit. Das heißt, man zerlegt das Licht über viele Wellen. Man braucht mehr Photon, man braucht einfach mehr Licht, um diese Messung zu machen. Während die Transit-Methode auch bei schwächeren Sternen gut funktioniert. Und nun ist es so, es gibt viel mehr lichtschwächere Sterne am Himmel als helle. Und da die geometrische Wahrscheinlichkeit hier so gering ist, einen Transit überhaupt zu sehen, hat man gesagt, na ich beobachte viele schwache Sterne, dann habe ich viele Sterne, sehe ich viele Transits. Niemand hat beim Bau von Kepler oder Corot an diese Nachfolgebeobachtung gedacht. Und jetzt ist es so, dass wir die große Vielfalt von Exoplaneten sehen. Wir möchten gerne mehr über sie erfahren und wir können nicht. Es ist so ein bisschen wie der Esel, der die Karotte vor der Nase hat und nie rankommt. Es ist sehr deprimierend.
Bevor wir jetzt auch noch auf die zukünftigen Bedarfe für die Beobachtung kommen. Ich kann mich ja noch erinnern, dass im Prinzip so vor 20, 25 Jahren, also bevor überhaupt diese Nachricht einschlug, jetzt hat man auch mal einen Planeten gefunden. Allgemein immer so ein bisschen die Frage war, gibt es denn überhaupt noch andere Planeten? Man kann sich zwar ein bisschen darüber nachdenken, schwer vorstellen, dass wir jetzt so mega einzigartig sind, aber wir wissen ja auch, dass gerade auch dieses Bild des Menschen von der Welt immer so ein bisschen von so einer Einzigartigkeit. Der Mensch ist einzigartig, die Erde ist einzigartig, alles gibt es nur einmal, alles ist besonders. Umso mehr wir eigentlich immer erforscht haben und nach außen geschaut haben, haben wir einfach festgestellt so, nee, gibt es auch, gibt es auch, gibt es auch, das gibt es auch noch, wir sind irgendwie gar nicht so besonders. Und jetzt ist im Prinzip dann auch noch so die Bastion Planet gefallen und der Suchen nach der zweiten Erde ist ja im Prinzip letzten Endes auch so, die Bestätigung für, naja, also auch Erde gibt es irgendwie wie Sand am Meer. Was hat man denn jetzt sozusagen herausgefunden, wie normal sind Planeten an sich? Hat irgendwie alles, also hat jede Sonne auch Planeten? Und wie normal ist unsere Art von Sonnensystem?
Planeten sind normal. Also das können wir heute sicher sagen und ich finde es sehr faszinierend. Sie, ich, wir alle sind die erste Generation der Menschheit, die weiß, wirklich weiß, dass es andere Planeten-Systeme gibt. Das muss man sich schon mal wieder klar machen, dass das ein wirklicher Schritt ist. Ich weiß, viele Leute halten es normal, weil man es durch Science-Fiction und Hollywood, sich jeder schon mit diesem Gedanken irgendwie angefreundet hat. Hab ich ja im Fernsehen gesehen. Aber ich denke, wir sollten es schon noch unterscheiden zwischen dem, was unsere Fantasie ist, auch wenn wir Fantasie für plausibel halten, was Fantasie ist und was Wissen ist. Und wir sind die erste Generation der Menschheit, die das weiß. Wir wissen, es gibt Planeten um andere Sterne. Was wir auch wissen, ist, dass es Planetensysteme gibt, die ganz anders aussehen als unser Sonnensystem. Wir haben jetzt etwa 2000 gesicherte Planeten. Wir haben noch mal 3000, 4000 Planetenkandidaten von der Kepler-Mission, wo wir nur wissen, dass sie Planeten sind, aber die Parameter nicht genau bestimmen können.
Auf wie viele Planetensysteme oder Sonnensysteme verteilt sich das?
Auf die aktuellste Zahl aus dem Internet habe ich jetzt nicht ganz im Kopf. Die letzte Zahl, die ich im Kopf habe, war etwas zwischen 600 bis 700 Systeme. Das heißt, von mindestens zwei bis...
Also 600, 700 Sonnen, von denen man weiß, dass ein oder mehrere Planeten da sind.
Genau. Plus einige Einplanetensysteme, also Planeten plus Sternen. Diese Planetensysteme sind zum Teil sehr anders als unsere. Über die heißen Planeten haben wir schon gesprochen. Heiße Gasriesen, heiße terrestrische Planeten wie Koro 7W. Planeten auf sehr elliptischen Bahnen, auch etwas, was im Sonnensystem nicht gibt. Sonnensystems sind alle bahnenetwa kreisförmig. Planetensysteme, die sehr koplanar sind, d.h. man sieht Transits von bis zu sechs Planeten. Diese liegen also extrem in einer Ebene. Wir haben Planetensysteme, wo der Planet nicht in der Äquatoebene um den Stern läuft, das auch sehr möglich ist, geklärt werden kann. Und wir haben vor allen Dingen die Diversität der Planeten, die eben Klassen enthält, die es bei uns nicht gibt. Vor allen Dingen diesen Übergangsbereich zwischen den kleinen Gesteinsplaneten und den Gasriesen, der offensichtlich gefüllt ist mit allen möglichen Typen von Planeten. Nicht in unserem Sonnensystem, aber wenn wir raus schauen, dann ist das so. Es ist schon ein bisschen so ein, wie sollen wir sagen, wir sind in einem Zeitalter, wenn Sie Botaniker sind und Sie haben bisher ein Gänseblümchen gekannt, Ihren Baum und Ihre Topfgeranie. Und dann gehen Sie mal raus in den Urwald und entdecken, was gibt es? Also alles so.
Alle Formen und Farben und Größenordnungen.
Genau. Und wir sind noch in der Phase, wo wir auch erstmal korrelieren wollen, schauen wollen, was ist da draußen? Was ist typisch, was ist nicht typisch? Dazu reicht die Zahl der Planeten bisher noch nicht aus. 2000 klingt zwar viel, aber wenn Sie überlegen, dass Sie das korrelieren wollen mit dem Stern, mit den verschiedenen Sterntypen, mit dem Alter, mit den Größen, mit der Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre und so weiter, dann dünnt das leider immer weiter aus.
Aber wenn man es jetzt mal hochrechnet und sagt, ok, jetzt haben wir so und so viele Systeme beobachtet, so und so viele Planeten gefunden.
Genau, das können wir gut machen mit der Kepler-Mission. Wenn wir mal sagen, die Kepler-Kandidaten mit dazu nehmen, dann haben wir 5000, 6000 Planeten. Und dann hat man schon eine Zahl, mit der man mal arbeiten kann. Nehmen wir mal an, die Kandidaten sind auch alle reale Planeten. Und dann zeigt sich, dass die Hälfte aller Sterne, die Kepler untersucht hat, die Hälfte aller Sterne hat einen kleinen Planeten. Kleiner ist Neptun, oder Neptun groß oder kleiner. Und das ist auch faszinierend. Wenn Sie am Himmel schauen, dann hat jeder zweite Stern, den Sie sehen, einen Planeten.
Also bei so 100, 200 Milliarden Sonnen, die wir allein in der Milchstraße haben, können wir schon mal davon ausgehen, dass wir so zwischen 50 und 100 Milliarden davon auch wirklich Planeten haben, die dann 3, 4, 5, was weiß ich, wie viele sind. Wir blicken auf eine genauso unfassbare Zahl von Planeten und noch unfassbare Zahl, als wir das schon bei Sonnen wissen.
Genau, das wissen wir schon, das ist auch relativ gesichert. Jedenfalls bis zum Abstand, sagen wir Merkur. Das ist so der Abstand, für den die Kepler-Statistik sehr gut ist, Abstand von der Sonne. Wenn ich jetzt sage, jetzt haben Sie noch gefragt, was wissen wir über Planetensysteme, die uns am Ende nennen? Dazu muss man halt sagen, ja, im Moment haben wir noch nicht viele gefunden. Wir können mit der Radiageschwindigkeitsmethode zum Beispiel sehr wohl Jupiter auf der Jupiter-Bahn finden, hat man auch viele gefunden. Gasriesen, die etwa weit weg sind. Anscheinend ohne innere Gesteinsplaneten im Moment, ist aber auch schwierig zu entdecken. Unser Sonnensystem ist im Moment an der Messgrenze und die Kepler-Statistik für das berühmte Etter-Earths, nämlich die Frequenz, mit der Erden um Sonnensysteme analog auftreten. Dieser Zahl ist im Moment sehr, sehr unsicher. Und deswegen baut man weitere Satellitenmissionen, nämlich erst mal kleine Satellitenmissionen, TESS und KEOBS und dann die Mission PLATO in zehn Jahren.
Was sind das jetzt für neue Missionen? Ich würde jetzt erst mal von dem, was Sie gesagt haben, vermuten, da muss jetzt erst mal die Erkenntnis der Wichtigkeit der Sternenbeobachtung einfach mit einfließen. Man muss einfach andere Instrumente oder zumindest andere Instrumentgenauigkeiten an den Start bringen.
Also was man zuerst mit einfließen lässt, ist die Erkenntnis, dass die Sterne, die Zentralsterne des Planeten-Systems, was man entdeckt, möglichst hell sein sollen. Ich muss also Planeten nicht irgendwo suchen, sondern ich muss Planeten suchen im helle Sterne, weil ich nur für die hellen Sterne hinterher vom Boden mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode die Masse bestimmen kann. Und ohne Massebestimmung und Radiusbestimmung kriege ich die mittlere Dichte nicht. Ich weiß also nicht genau, was habe ich da eigentlich für ein Objekt. Ich weiß zwar, es ist ein Planet, aber wenn ich dann wissen will, was ist denn das überhaupt für ein Planeten, ein Gesteinsplaneten, Minigasplaneten, dann muss ich die Dichte haben.
Und so eine Radialbeobachtung auch noch von dem Satelliten aus zu machen?
Ist nicht mal. Ist nicht. Ist zu aufwendig, nicht machbar. Ist auch nicht kosteneffektiv. Sondern das kann man vom Boden gut machen. Man baut also jetzt eine nächste Generation von Satelliten, die zurzeit im Bau sind. Einmal auf der europäischen, einmal auf der NASA-Seite. Das sind kleine Missionen. Auf der europäischen Seite ist es die Mission Keops. Das ist die erste Kleinsatellitemission der ESA. Das Instrument läuft unter der Entwicklung der Schweizer Kollegen aus Bern. Das ist ein Spiegel, 27 cm groß. Eine Kamera mit einem Spiegel, der immer einen Stern aufnimmt. Das Besondere an Keops ist, dass es nicht Planeten direkt suchen will, sondern bei Keops hat man die Gedanken umgedreht. Man hat gesagt, die Planeten, die man mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode findet, für die habe ich ja schon die Masse. Mit der Methode sind es auch automatisch helle Sterne. Wenn ich für die einen Transit sehe, dann habe ich den Radius dazu, dann habe ich die mittlere Dichtung, dann habe ich meine Info. Das heißt, Keops wird Planeten anschauen, die mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode gefunden wurden. Wo es aber noch keine Transitbeobachtung gibt. Also eine Radius gibt es noch nicht, dann müssen wir eine Radius bestimmen. Und weitere Kandidaten für Keops sind Planeten, die durch Transit entdeckt wurden, zum Beispiel vom Boden, wo aber der Radius ein riesen Fehlerbalken hat, wo man das natürlich vom Weltraum aus viel genauer bekommen kann. Das heißt, Keops ist eine Nachfolge-Mission. Das ist das erste Mal, dass man Transit als Nachfolgebeobachtung nimmt. Normalerweise ist es immer umgekehrt. Man entdeckt mit dem Transit. Und wenn man die Masse will, macht man die Radialgeschwindigkeit vom Boden. Und dort ist der Gedanke, das umzudrehen. Die Mission soll 2018 starten. In den USA wird auch 2017 und 2018 starten. Die Mission TESS. TESS ist auch eine sehr, sehr interessante Mission. TESS wird den gesamten Himmel abscannen. TESS hat vier kleine Teleskope, 10 cm Öffnung, Linsen, Refraktoren. TESS, T-E-S-S. Diese vier Teleskope schauen immer in einen Quadranten vom Himmel. Also es sind so in einer Linie, eins schaut zum Pol, eins schaut Richtung Äquato und die anderen beiden dazwischen. Und so wird TESS den gesamten Himmel abscannen, erst die Nordhalbkugel. Es schaut also ein Stückchen, einen Streifen Nordhalbkugel an, für einen Monat. Dann geht es ein Stück weiter, wieder einen Monat, noch ein Stück weiter, einen Monat, in einem Jahr ist er einmal rum. Und dann das gleiche nochmal in der Südhalbkugel. Das heißt, in zwei Jahren hat TESS den gesamten Himmel abgescannt. Die Teleskope sind sehr klein, 10 cm Öffnung, das heißt ganz klar ausgelegt auf helle Sterne, für die man dann auch ganz leicht die Radialgeschwindigkeitsnachfolge Beobachtung machen kann. Das ist also eine tolle Mission. Wir werden das erste Mal eine Gesamtdurchmistung und Musterung des Himmels bekommen. Das hatten wir mit Corot und Kepler und K2 nicht. Die haben immer auf ausgewählte Bildfelder nur schauen können.
Das heißt, man konzentriert sich aber auch da auf helle Sterne?
Der Witz ist helle Sterne. Das ist die große Erkenntnis von Corot und Kepler. Ich hab ja von dieser Karotte gespannt, wie ihr nicht rankam. Und man kommt aber ran, wenn man helle Sterne beobachtet.
Darauf konzentriert sich TESS und macht halt das erste Mal eine komplette Kartografierung im Prinzip.
Genau, einmal den gesamten Himmel abgescannt. Und das ist natürlich auch nochmal etwas Neues, weil man nicht weiß, ob die Bildfelder, die wir bisher angeschaut haben mit den Satellitmissionen, ob es vielleicht Unterschiede gibt, ob ich an verschiedene Regionen am Himmel schaue. Ob diese Bildfelder vielleicht irgendwas spezielles hatten.
Heißt denn eigentlich helle Sterne im Wesentlichen Nahelsterne? Oder ist das immer noch auch große Sterne?
Es heißt im Wesentlichen Nahelsterne. Es heißt natürlich auch große Sterne. Große Sterne sind noch hell, wenn sie weiter weg sind.
Aber vor allem schauen wir die unmittelbare Nachbarschaft.
Vor allem schauen wir unsere Nachbarschaft bis zu 100 Lichtjahren.
Das heißt, so eine Kartografierung ist nicht nur interessant, weil man daraus noch sehr viel mehr Informationen herausziehen kann, sondern das ist ja dann auch noch sehr viel wertvoller bei der statistischen Berechnung, mit wie viel gibt es denn überhaupt, weil wir unser unmittelbares Umfeld einmal komplett abgeklappert haben.
Das sind also die tollen Ziele der TESS-Mission. Was man im Kopf haben muss, ist allerdings, dass TESS immer nur einen Monat auf ein Bildfeld schaut. Sie haben zwar eine kleine Region an den Polen, wo sich die Bildfelder überlappen, wo man eine kontinuierliche Überdeckung hat, aber die ganz große Zahl der Daten heißt, einen Monat Zeit geschaut. Und wenn ich dann überlege, ich muss drei Transit haben, also die Kepler-Statistik und Vorhersagen sagen, dass die meisten Planeten, die TESS finden wird, die meisten Planeten, die TESS finden wird, sind bis zu 20 Tagen Umlaufperiode. Das heißt, wir bekommen eine komplette Himmelsdurchmusterung für Planeten bis 20 bis 30 Tage Umlaufperiode. Ich erinnere nochmal, dass der Merkur 3 Monate, 88 Tage Umlaufperiode.
Aber es gibt ja auch relativ viele Systeme, die solche geringen Umlaufzeiten von Planeten haben.
Genau. Und was jetzt noch übrig bleibt, zu tun bleibt nach TESS und CHEOPS, ist ganz klar, wir wollen natürlich nicht nur die heißen Planeten entdecken und untersuchen, sondern wir wollen das Gleiche machen für Planeten, die weiter weg sind. Nämlich in dem Bereich, wo wir die terrestrischen Planeten im Sonnensystem haben. Also Umlaufperioden von 80 Tagen bis zu einem Jahr. Und hier setzt dann die europäische PLATO-Mission an, die 2024 starten soll. PLATO ist die M3-Mission der ESA. M steht für Mittelklasse. Also eine Mittelklasse-Mission, wobei Mittelklasse auch schon recht groß ist. Die jetzt ausgewählt wurde 2014 und nächstes Jahr hoffentlich dann ihre Mission Adoption bekommt. PLATO besteht aus 34 kleinen Teleskopen.
Also Adoption heißt, dass dann auch das wirklich durchgeführt wird, finanziert wird und zum Start kommt.
Bei der ESA ist es ein Mehrstufenprozess. Sie werden erst aus einer großen Zahl von Missionsvorschlägen ausgewählt für Studien, schließlich ausgewählt als Mission. Das haben wir 2014 geschafft. Und jetzt haben wir noch eine Designphase. Und in der Mitte dieser Designphase gibt es diesen Prozess der Adoption, dass man sagt, ja, das ist wirklich machbar und funktioniert, so wie erwartet. Und danach ist es bei ESA beschlossen. ESA ist ja eine Weltraum-Agentur, die die Mission, die sie dann wirklich beschlossen haben, auch immer durchführt. Das ist ja so, dass jede ESA-Mission, die adoptiert wurde, auch am Ende geflogen ist, auch wenn sie beim Start explodiert wäre oder so etwas, dann wird das eben noch bisher gemacht. So hat ESA das bisher immer gehandhabt.
Also es ist sozusagen der Point of No Return.
Genau.
Dann wird das auch gemacht. Und dort haben sie auch eine spezielle Rolle. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, sind sie ja Leiterin des Instrumenten-Konsortiums. Das heißt, sie überblicken im Prinzip, was jetzt tatsächlich auf Plateau an Instrumenten zum Einsatz kommt und koordinieren das mit den entsprechenden Erbauern und Betreibern dieser Instrumente.
Genau, also wir haben ein Instrumenten-Konsortium aus europäischen Instituten, Partnerinstituten, über ganz Europa verteilt, das ich koordiniere und leite.
Das ist wirklich ausschließlich europäische Instrumentenanbauer?
Ja, also wir haben eine kleine Beteiligung für Software-Testen aus Brasilien noch dazu. Aber die große Mehrheit sind europäische Institute, europäische Weltrauminstitute und Universitäten, die da mitmachen.
Und wie viele Instrumente werden das denn so sein?
PLATO hat 34 kleine Teleskope, Refraktoren, also Linsenteleskope, 12 cm Öffnung. Etwa, meine italienischen Kollegen haben es immer gesagt, so groß wie eine große Kaffeemaschine. Aber 34 davon, die Plattform, auf die die Teleskope montiert werden, wird etwa so 5 Meter Durchmesser haben, wo wir so 34 Teleskope vorstellen können. Der Grund für dieses sehr ungewöhnliche Design liegt daran, dass wir helle Sterne beobachten wollen, darüber haben wir jetzt schon recht lang gesprochen. Andererseits aber Planeten entdecken wollen, das heißt wieder viele Sterne. Und viele heißt schwache, weil es gibt eben nicht so viele Helle. Sodass man einen sehr großen dynamischen Bereich braucht, so nennen wir das, wenn wir über einen sehr großen Helligkeitsbereich messen wollen. Und das kann man ganz gut, wenn man statt einem großen Spiegel, wie es sonst traditionell ist, viele kleine Teleskope nimmt. Für die hellsten Sterne reicht dann ein Teleskop mit 10 cm Öffnung aus. Und für die schwesten Sterne braucht man alle 32.
Das heißt, man kann im Prinzip sehr viel besser skalieren. Wenn man mit einem großen, große Lichtausbeute hätte, würde man aber durch zu helle Sterne quasi geblendet werden.
Überbelichtet werden, genau.
Und bei Schwachen wäre man unter Umständen dann zu unterdimensioniert. Und so skaliert man das, indem man einfach weitere Module hinzunimmt. So macht das ja auch das Very Large Teleskop. Ehe so, ist ja auch ähnlich geplant. Also man geht weg von diesem, man hat eine Schüssel, sondern man nimmt einfach quasi eine parallele Beobachtung und summiert die Lichtsignale der einzelnen Messungen.
Genau, das ist der Gedanke. Und man hat 32, was wir normale Teleskope nennen. Normal heißt, die Teleskope haben keine Filter, operieren im weißen Licht, werden alle 25 Sekunden und wird der CCD-Detektor, der Halbleiterdetektor, ausgelesen. Wir haben diese Teleskope in vier Gruppen aufgeteilt, mit jeweils acht, die sich überlappen. In der Mitte schauen alle 32 Teleskope in eine Richtung, und an den Ecken haben wir dann immer noch acht. Die Teleskope sind nicht beweglich, das ist so ein festes Muster, was dann auf den Himmel schaut. Und zu diesen 32 normalen Teleskopen kommen zwei schnelle Teleskope, die sehr schnell ausgelesen werden, alle zweieinhalb Sekunden, die zusammen mit dem Satelliten die sehr, sehr genaue Steuerung des Satelliten sicherstellen. Der Punkt ist, dass die Photometrie-Messung, wenn wir sie zu einer Erde oder eine Sonne treiben wollen, sehr, sehr genau sein muss. Das heißt, der Satellit muss so stabil ausgerichtet sein, dass die Sterne immer auf dem gleichen Pixel des Detektors bleiben. Und zwar auf Subpixel-Genauigkeit. Und um diese Feinsteuerung des Satelliten zu machen, sind zwei Teleskope so ausgestattet, dass sie schneller ausgelesen werden, um eine sehr, sehr schnelle und gute Regelung mit dem Satelliten zu bekommen. Die zwei Teleskope bekommen auch noch jeweils einen Filter, also ein blaues und ein rotes Filter. Das wird in der Astrosythmologie den Kollegen dort helfen, ihre Daten zu analysieren für bestimmte Sterne.
Das heißt, diese Teleskope sind nicht nur zur Positionierung da, aber werden auch dafür verwendet. Und dadurch, dass man sie schneller auslesen kann, hat man sozusagen eine höhere Abtastfrequenz für die Navigation und kann sich dann bei den anderen voll auf die Beobachtung konsumieren.
Genau, diese zwei Teleskope dienen hauptsächlich der Navigation, aber bieten eben nebenbei auch noch sehr gute Lichtkurven für nicht sehr viele Sterne, aber für etwa einige Dutzend Sterne, für die Astroseismologie, die dann auch noch Farbe hat, sodass es für diese Sterne nochmal eine besondere Qualität ist, für die Astroseismologie. Ansonsten haben wir die 32 in weißem Licht operierenden Teleskope, die eben auf hellere Sterne, weil die Öffnung der Teleskope kleiner ist, auf hellere Sterne gehen können und damit die Nachfolgebeobachtung vom Boden ermöglichen, also uns das ermöglichen, was Kepler nicht konnte. Das Platobildfeld ist sehr groß, ungefähr 50 mal 50 Grad, so größer ist das Keplerbildfeld war. Und wir werden erst mal zwei Bildfelder beobachten, eins am Süden, eins am Nordhimmel, für drei und zwei Jahre, zielt also auf Erden um die Sonne, so lange Langzeitfelder beobachten. Und hinterher noch eine, das was wir Step- und Stairphase nennen, also eine Phase, in der wir für einige Monate auf verschiedene Felder am Himmel schauen. Insgesamt sechs Jahre Beobachtungsdauer sind geplant, mit einer Option für zwei Jahre und noch zu verlängern. Sowas entscheidet sich dann aber erst am Ende der sechs Jahre.
Das Besondere ist ja auch, wie man das schon bei ein paar anderen Weltraumbeobachtungsmissionen in den letzten Jahren gesehen hat, hier jetzt nicht in einem Orbit um die Erde geflogen wird, sondern letztlich schon, aber es geht hier vor allem um das Anfliegen eines Lagrange-Punktes. Lagrange 2 ist glaube ich hier, also hinter der Erde sozusagen.
Genau, hinter der Erde, von der Sonne aus gesehen.
Wo auch Planck und Herschel schon gewaltet haben.
Und Gaia.
Und Gaia, genau.
Das heißt, wir gehen in den Lagrange-Punkt 2. Auch das wird ein ein vorteilhafteres Orbit sein. Kuro war im Erdorbit, niederen Erdorbit, bei zwischen 500, 600 Kilometern Höhe. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht genau an die. In einem Erdorbit. Kepler war in einem Earth Trailing Orbit. Also immer auf der gleichen Bahn der Erde, aber hinter der Erde hergeflogen. Der Lagrange-Punkt bietet uns natürlich wesentlich mehr Flexibilität in der Auswahl der Bildfelder für Plato.
Man kann ja nicht irgendwo hinfliegen, weil man muss ja auch noch Kommunikation aufrecht erhalten und das kostet ja auch dann eine Menge Sprit. Aber dieser Lagrange-Punkt hat einfach den Vorteil, dass man quasi mit der Erde mitgeführt wird, aber eben auch deutlich weiter weg ist von der Sonne.
Genau, und die Sonne immer gut im Rücken haben kann, sodass die Sonne kein Streulichter zeugt. Weil Streulicht würde natürlich wieder die Messung sehr, sehr erschweren. Das darf nicht sein.
Genau, das war ja im Prinzip auch so der Punkt bei Planck, bei der Beobachtung der Hintergrundstrahlung des Universums, man wollte da halt einfach in Ruhe gelassen werden von der Sonne. Aber eben nicht so weit weg von der Erde, dass man nicht auch die Möglichkeit gehabt hätte, auch die Daten zurückzufunken.
Wir würden im Prinzip einige Terabyte Daten pro Tag erzeugen. Wir erzeugen mit den 34 Teleskopen viel mehr Daten, als wir zur Erde zurückschicken können. Wir können also nicht einfach die ganzen Bilder auslesen. Das geschieht nur in regelmäßigen Abständen für Kalibration, aber nicht als Datenrate, sondern leider muss man sich beschränken. Dass man was auch Kepler schon gemacht hat, ist auch ein bewährtes Prinzip. Man macht also um die Zielsterne herum eine kleine Maske und lädt nur die Pixel zum Boden, die in dieser Maske liegen. Bei Coro nannte man das Imaget, die Amerikaner nennen es Post-it-Stemp. Also so ein Ausschnitt aus dem Bildfeld herum um den Stern, den man dann zum Boden...
Da holt man sich die Rohdaten...
Genau, die meisten Rohdaten werden dann am Boden prozessiert für die Lichtschwächerensterne machen wir es auch am Satelliten, also in Mischung, aber für die Hellen, die uns besonders interessieren, die besonders wertvoll sind, schicken wir diese Ausschnitte an den Boden und machen die Prozessierung am Boden. Das hat den Vorteil, dass man auch lernen kann, dass man also die Original-Rohdaten am Boden hat und lernen kann während der Beobachtungsphase. Alles, was man lernt über Verbesserungen, die in die Datenprozessierung eingehen könnte, kann man dann wieder rückwirkend auf die Rohdaten anwenden. Das ist ja immer der Nachteil, wenn Sie Prozessierung nur am Satelliten machen, dass es dann schwerer ist, noch mal zu verändern, weil die Daten nicht aufgehoben werden können. Wir haben nicht das Memory, um auf dem Satelliten alle die Daten zu speichern.
Wird den Plateau auch noch mal zusätzlich gekühlt?
Nein, also gekühlt einfach durch die... Im Gegenteil, wir müssen es heizen, um es auf der idealen CCD-Temperatur zu haben. Auch interessant ist die... Also, Plateau-CCDs müssen auf ihrer Temperatur gehalten werden, arbeitet im weißen Licht. Wir haben also nicht das Problem wie Infrarot-Detektoren, wo sie speziell kühlen müssen oder so. Was wir bei Plateau machen müssen, ist die Fokalsteuerung, die ebenfalls thermisch erzeugt, indem wir die thermischen Expansionen vom Material einfach benutzen, die die Linsen halten, um die Linsen ein bisschen zu bewegen und in Fokus zu halten. Das Ziel ist, möglichst wenig Mechanik in so einem Satelliten zu haben, wie es bei allen anderen Missionen auch ist.
Was versprechen Sie sich denn jetzt von der Mission Plateau an Erkenntnissen? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt viel über besser, mehr und so weiter gesprochen. Das spielt natürlich eine große Rolle und wird letzten Endes auch beitragen. Aber was sind denn noch so die Unbekannten, worum man jetzt hinaus will? Also was wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben, was jetzt vielleicht so fürs Ende nochmal auch ein interessanter Ausblick wäre, ist dieser Aspekt zu leben auf anderen Planeten. Was versprechen Sie sich sozusagen jetzt von der zukünftigen Entwicklung und was zeichnet sich vielleicht auch jetzt schon mit der bisherigen Erkenntnislage und eben auch dem Trend in der technischen Weiterentwicklung der Beobachtungsmission? Was zeichnet sich ab? Was verspricht sozusagen auch dieses Exoplaneten-Forschungsfeld insgesamt?
Ja, was wir gelernt haben aus Kuro, Kepler und jetzt aus K2-Lern, ist einfach, dass die Vielfalt der Planeten größer ist, als wir sie im Soddensystem haben. Das möchte man verstehen. Man möchte mir erstmal mehr über die Planeten erfahren. Was sind das für Planeten? Gibt es da welche, die Leben haben könnten? Generell, wie sind Planeten-Systeme entstanden? Passt das mit unserer Theorie zusammen? Oder muss man sich doch noch was anderes überlegen? Oder andere Aspekte hineinbringen? Das sind so die Fragen. Das Ganze geht schrittweise deswegen, weil es natürlich mit der technischen Entwicklung einhergehen muss. Der nächste Schritt geht jetzt gemacht mit den Transit-Surveys, die im Bau sind. Also KIOBS, TESS, PLATO. Diese Surveys werden uns liefern die Dichten der Planeten, sodass wir erstmal diese Erkenntnis der verschiedenen Planetentypen, diese Grobklassifizierung durchführen können und erstmal Exploration machen können. Was sind typische Planeten? Warum gibt es keine großen Gasriesen und kleine Sterne? Gibt es Entwicklungen mit dem Alter? Was sind die Architekturen?
Wie viele Modelle muss man unterscheiden?
Genau. Das werden wir machen können. PLATO soll uns liefern die erste gesicherte Erde in der habitablen Zone um einen Stern, also in der bewohnbaren Zone, wo wir wirklich wissen, das ist ein Gesteinsplanet und nicht ein Minigasplanet.
Der bisher noch nicht gefunden wurde.
Der bisher noch nicht gefunden wurde. Das ist das große Ziel von PLATO. Und wenn möglich nicht nur ein, sondern eine Handvoll, dass man zumindest eine minimale statistische Aussage machen kann, die nicht auf Kandidaten beruht, sondern auf wirklich Planeterkenntnissen. Das ist die eine Linie der Klassifikation des Big Pictures, sag ich mal. Wenn ich in Richtung Leben und Habitabilität gehe, reicht es natürlich nicht. Wenn ich wissen will, ob ein Planet habitabel ist, bewohnbar ist, muss ich erst zwei Dinge wissen. Erstmal muss ich wissen, ist überhaupt ein Gesteinsplanet. Weil wir uns Leben in Gasriesen, sowas wie Jupiter, nicht vorstellen können. Es ist etwas, das nicht Leben wie wir es kennen. Wir reden ohnehin immer nur über Leben, wie wir es kennen. Weil anderes Leben kann ich nicht suchen. Genau. Also Leben in Gasriesen fällt dann weg. Das heißt, ich brauche einen Planeten, der eine Gesteinsoberfläche hat. Das wird uns dann Plato liefern können, überhaupt Erkenntnis über solche Planeten. Der Planet muss im richtigen Abstand vom Stern sein, sodass Wasser auf der Oberfläche flüssig bleiben kann. Das liegt daran, dass alle Biologen sagen, Leben hat sich in Wasser entwickelt. Also brauchen wir Wasser.
Vielleicht gibt es verschiedene Arten von Leben, aber die eine kennen wir auf jeden Fall, und die ist für uns auch am interessantesten.
Genau, das ist das einzige Leben, was wir kennen, und das braucht Wasser zu seiner Entwicklung. Leben, wie wir ja wissen von den Kollegen, auch die entsprechende Forschung machen kann, auch lange Zeit mal ohne Wasser auskommen, aber irgendwann braucht es wieder Wasser. Zumindest zur Entwicklung, zum Entstehen braucht es Wasser. Und das ist dann auch schon für uns extrasolare Planetenforscher die Definition von Habitabilität. Die ist sehr einfach, sie macht sich fest an dem Typ von Planeten, ein Gesteinsplaneten, der flüssiges Wasser auf der Oberfläche haben kann. Wir wissen natürlich von den Kollegen aus dem Sonnensystem, dass das nicht alles ist, sondern wir wissen auch, es braucht auch Nahrung für Leben, es braucht stabile Klimabedingungen. Manche Kollegen argumentieren, dass wir Planeten wie die Erde brauchen mit Tektonik, mit Langzeitklimastabilisierung und so. Das sind natürlich Dinge, die sich bei extrasolanen Planeten erstmal der direkten Messung entziehen. Aber wenn ich sage, ich brauche einen Planeten, der flüssiges Wasser auf der Oberfläche hat, dann definiert mir das Oberflächenbedingungen im Sinne von Temperatur und Druck. Und dann bin ich bei etwas, das kann man messen. Da fühle ich mich als Physikerin wieder mehr zu Hause als in der Biologie. Das ist also etwas, das kann man messen. Das heißt, ich muss erstmal einen Planeten finden, der ein Gesteinsplanet in der habitablen Zone liegt, also in dem Abstandsbereich, wo das möglich wäre. Das ist Punkt eins. Wenn ich den dann habe, heißt das natürlich noch lange nicht, dass der bewohnbar ist. Wenn Sie bei uns im Sonnensystem schauen, wir haben die Erde, die ist bei einer astronomischen Einheit, die ist wunderbar habitabel, bewohnbar. Vielleicht heute im Regen nicht so, aber im Prinzip. Dann haben Sie aber den Mond, der besteht auch aus Gesteinen, und der ist nicht bewohnbar. Das heißt, allein das Finden eines Gesteinsplaneten im richtigen Abstand genügt nicht. Da muss nur ein Schritt mehr dazu kommen. Und was muss dazu kommen? Die Atmosphäre. Der Unterschied zwischen dem Mond und der Erde ist, dass die Erde eben eine Atmosphäre hat, die uns die entsprechenden Oberflächenbedingungen erlaubt und uns hier Leben erlaubt. Und das zeigt Ihnen auch schon, wie der Gang der Dinge bei der Extoplanitenforschung ist. Das, was wir heute recht gut messen können, was also im Bereich der Methoden ist und der Instrumente, die jetzt gebaut werden, ist, erstmal bestimmen, haben wir da Gesteinsplaneten. Dazu brauche ich Massen und Radien, dazu wenden wir die Methoden an. Die Instrumente sind im Bau. Das machen wir nicht nur für einen, sondern viele, weil man die Variabilität und Exploration machen will. Was ist da? Das nächste ist, ich muss schauen, haben die Planeten eine Atmosphäre.
Kann man denn das mit dem bisherigen Messsystem schon machen?
Das kann man machen und das ist auch ganz faszinierend für die Gasriesen, für die heißen Gasriesen. Und zwar nutzt man wieder die Transit-Methode. Und zwar hat die Transit-Methode, also ich muss in irgendeiner Form das Planetensignal der Planetenatmosphäre vom Stern trennen. Wenn ich den Planeten räumlich aufgelöst neben dem Stern sehe, also ein Foto machen kann, dann ist das einfach. Dann kann ich auch einen Spektrografenspalt über den Planeten legen und direkt ein Spektrum machen, schauen, ist da eine Atmosphäre. Das geht aber eben nur bei sehr wenigen Objekten, wie wir am Anfang besprochen haben. Eine andere Möglichkeit zu trennen, ist durch die Transit-Methode gegeben. Wenn ich den Planeten vor dem Stern stehen habe, dann geht das Licht des Sterns durch die Planetenatmosphäre zu uns.
Das heißt, es wird nicht nur schwächer dadurch, was man vor allem erstmal beobachtet hat, sondern man hat auch eine Veränderung in der Spektroskopie, weil natürlich die ganzen Elemente, die in dieser Atmosphäre drinstecken, dann da einen Einfluss haben.
Genau, weil die Moleküle, die in der Planetenatmosphäre sind, nochmal Licht vom Stern absorbieren, das dann nicht zu uns kommen kann. Wenn jetzt der Planet weiterzieht auf seiner Bahn, ist er irgendwann durchgezogen und ich hab nur noch das Sternenlicht. Dann mess ich das Sternenlicht und Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn ich die beiden Spektren voneinander abziehe, was übrig bleibt, ist das Signal vom Planeten.
Das wird aber auch schon gemacht.
Das wird gemacht im optischen Bereich. Wenn ich das im Infrarot-Bereich mache, kann ich zwar die sekundäre Eklipse ausnutzen, nämlich wenn der Planet dann weitergeht, irgendwann verschwindet er ja hinterm Stern. Kurz bevor er hinterm Stern verschwindet, sehe ich ja die Tagseite des Planeten. Wenn ich im Infrarot messe, sehe ich das Signal, die Wärmestrahlung, die vom Planeten ausgeht und durch seine Atmosphäre zu uns geht. Auch da kann ich wieder Moleküle in der Planetenatmosphäre nachweisen. Man kann also im optischen messen und im Infraroten. Das hat den Vorteil, dass man gerade im nahen Infraroten solche Moleküle sehen kann wie Wasser, Ozone, CO2, Kohlenmonoxid, also die Atmosphäre und vor allen Dingen auch die Treibhausgase, die wichtig sind, um einen Einfluss auf das Klima auf dem Planeten zu haben. Und natürlich, wenn man mal an Leben denkt, dann möchte man nachweisen Sauerstoff oder indirekt Ozone, was aus Sauerstoff erzeugt wird. Und diese Moleküle sind zugänglich in diesem wellenlängen Bereich. Das heißt, diese Messungen kann man machen. Technisch können wir sie heute machen nur für wenige Planeten, wieder helle Sterne. Ich brauch Planeten, die sehr helle Sterne umkreisen. Und heute kann man das machen für Gasplaneten, diese heißen Jupiter. Dort hat man schon nachgewiesen Wasser, Kohlenmonoxid, Kohlendioxid, Methan und noch einige andere Moleküle. Das sind natürlich in einem Gasriesen wie Jupiter nur Spurenstoffe und das Wasser in diesem Planeten oder Sauerstoff in so einem Planeten zeigt kein Leben an. Sondern es ist eben ein Spurenstoff, wie man diese Elemente auch in Jupiter findet.
Es wäre halt schon das Richtige da, aber man weiß halt noch nicht, was der Planet daraus gemacht hat.
Man hat das auch gemacht für Neptun große Planeten, heiße Neptune. Heiße Mini-Planeten, was ich eher sage, weil bei Neptun ist Neptun und der ist viel weiter weg. Aber das hat sich so eingebürgert. Also heiße Mini-Gasplaneten, die man hat, die in einem Massebereich sind, wo sie entweder so etwas wirklich, wie ein Planete mit einer Wasserstofffülle und Spurengasen oder aber auch einen großen Wasserdampfanteil haben könnten. Ganz spannend, also in dem Bereich sind es zwischen Mini-Gas und Super Erde. Dort hat man leider eine große Enttäuschung erlebt, nämlich die Spektren sind einfach flach. Es zeigen sich keine Absurptionssignale. Und das interpretiert man im Moment so, dass diese Planeten Wolken haben. Und das ist natürlich dann ein Pech, wenn die Planeten Wolken in großen Höhen haben, dann kann ich einfach nicht hineinschauen und dann ziehe ich die Unteratmosphäre nicht und kann die Komposition nach oben. Da habe ich einfach nicht genug Atmosphäre übrig. Die Luft ist zu dünn, um Signal zu erzeugen. Und man sieht nur das, was über den Wolken ist. Das reicht dann halt nicht aus, um ein Signal zu machen. Und das ist im Moment die grosse Sorge. Wie ist das mit den Wolken? Haben all diese kleinen Planeten Wolken, die uns die Messung kaputt machen oder eben noch nicht? Wir haben nicht genug Objekte, wo man diese Messung heute überhaupt machen kann.
Aber das ist ja genau das, was sich jetzt durch die künftigen Missionen dann eben auch ändern soll.
Genau. Für die heißen Planeten wird TESS-Kandidaten liefern. Und für die warmen Planeten, die nicht mehr heiß, sondern nur noch warm sind, weiter weg sind, wird PLATO solche Kandidaten liefern. Solche Ziele, mit denen man dann untersuchen kann. Mit dem James Webb Teleskop. Und heute für heiße Gasriesen macht man die Messung schon heute mit den existierenden Teleskopen und mit dem Hubble Space Teleskop. Mit dem Infrared-Spitzer-Satelliten wurden Messungen gemacht. Dann kriegen wir das James Webb Teleskop. Das ist in zwei Jahren startet. Zwei, drei Jahren startet.
Hoffentlich.
Letzte Woche wurde auf einer Tagung gesagt, es wird starten. Also ich hoffe es einfach.
Das ist dann sozusagen nochmal wie Hubble, bloß toller.
Genau. Und auf den Boden kommt das IELT, der ISO, das 30-Meter-Teleskop. Und man muss sehen, dass ein 30-Meter-Teleskop am Boden wirklich viel Lichtsammelfläche ist. Und auch in dem Bereich der Atmosphären wird viel machen können. Auch da ist ein Infrared-Spektrograf als eines der First-Light-Experimente vorgesehen. Vielleicht später dann auch ein optischer Spektrograf. Das heißt, das Gebiet der Atmosphärenforschung ist jetzt im Startlöchern, ist jetzt im Kommen. Natürlich, wenn man die Erde messen möchte und Biosignaturen in einer Erde, dann redet man von etwas anderem. Dann redet man von Mission im Weltall. Dort sollte ich Ariel erwähnen. Das ist ein Kandidat für M4, also die nächste Mittelklasse-Mission der ESA. Starttermin wäre dann für M4 ist 2026. Es sind im Moment, soweit ich weiß, fünf Kandidaten noch im Rennen. Und eine davon ist Ariel unter englischer Leitung. Das soll ein Spektrometer sein, in dem Atmosphären von Exoplaneten untersucht werden sollen, für Exoplaneten, mit der die Transits zeigen. Ariel möchte möglichst viele untersuchen, einige 10 bis 100 bis 500 Targets. Der Typ von Planeten werden sein Gasriesen bis Neptune, Mini-Neptune. Nicht geht in den Bereich der Erden. Das kann man mit einem Spiegel, der nur etwas größer ist als ein Meter, nicht machen. Das heißt, Sie sehen, wir werden in unseren nächsten 10, 20 Jahren bei Ariel, weiß man nicht, ob es ausgewählt wird, das muss man dann sehen. Aber auf jeden Fall haben wir das James Webb und die bodengebundenen Teleskope. Wir werden also auch bei Atmosphären eine Exploration machen im Bereich Gasriesen und Neptune. Parallel dazu gehen wir mit Plato in den Bereich der Erden um die Sonne bei größeren Abständen, im Sinne der Dichten, der Diversität, der Entdeckung erstmal, wie viele sind da wirklich.
Die schiere Masse zu erhöhen.
Genau, die Masse am Planeten. Die Masse am Planeten oder überhaupt mal eine gesicherte Erde, um eine Sonne zu finden. Um die dann auf Habitabilität und Atmosphäre untersuchen zu können, dann reden wir allerdings über was anderes. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie gehört haben, dass Sie davon mal gehört haben. Es gab in der ESA eine Mission Darwin und auf der NASA-Seite eine Mission TPF, Thrust Road Planet Finder. Die waren in den 80er, 90er, 2009 geplant worden, dann eingestellt, weil sich gezeigt hat, dass diese Missionen technisch noch zu komplex sind. Diese Missionen hatten das Ziel, Atmosphären von einer Erde nach Biosignaturen zu untersuchen. Darwin war ein Konzept mit fünf oder sechs, acht Meter großen Spiegeln im Weltall. Sie sehen, da redet man nicht mehr von mittlerer Klasse Mission, sondern Large Mission, die auch ein Land oder ein Kontinent kaum noch alleine macht. Das ist dann eine andere Liga, da sind wir dann in der nächstgrößeren Klasse. So zeigt sich auch die Entwicklung der Planeten. Darwin und T. Perfan haben sehr groß gedacht. Es hat sich bestätigt, wenn man eine Erde hat und ihre Biosignaturen messen muss, dass man dann so große Missionen braucht. Aber heute geht es erstmal dahin, zu verstehen, was wir da für Planeten haben, ihre Entwicklung zu verstehen und Ziele zu finden, zu bestätigen, ja, solche Erden sind da. Und ich bin mir sicher, wenn man erstmal eine gesicherte Erde um einen sonnenähnlichen Stern gefunden hat, dass dann auch wieder das Momentum da ist, um Gelder locker zu machen und Missionen, die in dieser Darwin-TPF-Klasse sind, zu planen und anzugehen.
Und was ist Ihr Tipp? Finden wir so eine Erde?
Ja, sicher. Also, dass sie da ist, ist klar. Ich denke, dass wir sie mit Plato finden. Dafür strengen wir uns so an. Noch zehn Jahre lang. Auf jeden Fall. Wann wir von einer solchen Erde Spektren bekommen, im Sinne von Atmosphäre und Biosignaturen, also Wasser, Sauerstoff und so, was wir in der Biosignatur verstehen. Ja, da gehen die Tipps sehr auseinander, meine Kollegen und mich. Ich würde sagen, noch 50 Jahre. Wenn Sie auf das ESA-Programm schauen, dann sehen Sie, dass L1 bis L3, also die dritte Large Mission, ja schon feststehen in Ihren Themen. Das trägt uns da ein bisschen die 2030er hinein. Das heißt, die nächste L-Mission ist der Termin, der überhaupt anvisiert werden könnte, wird an den 2040ern, 2050ern. Das ist halt noch lange hin. Bis dahin ist es klar, es hat sich gezeigt, dass der große Traum von 0 auf 195 der erste Planet entdeckt. Und dann gleich eine... Dass es nicht geht, nicht nur wegen der technischen Entwicklung, sondern auch weil die Planeten selber vielfältiger, komplizierter sind. Die Welt ist einfach komplizierter da draußen, als wir uns das gedacht haben. Und dass es auch Sinn macht, erst mal zu mehr zu verstehen und dann die Ziele für eine so teure und aufwendige Mission auch besser auswählen zu können.
Man muss vor allem auch mal sagen, es ist halt auch nicht jetzt nur so das Rennen einer zweiten Erde hinterher, von der man eigentlich ohne Hinweis, dass man sie nie erreicht. Man kann so bestenfalls so zur Kenntnis nehmen, ja, okay, da ist jetzt was, das könnte uns in irgendeiner Form ähnlich sein. Nicht jetzt unbedingt den Menschen, aber sozusagen einfach nur vom Planeten her. Aber es hat sich ja jetzt auch schon gezeigt, allein diese Suche danach und die Betrachtung bringt so viele grundlegende Erkenntnisse, die einfach für das Verstehen des Welt als einfach an sich wichtig sind, dass es sich von daher allein schon lohnt.
Ja, also wir langweilen uns nicht, sondern wir entdecken ständig Neues. Jeder Parameter, den man anschaut, ist neu, zeigt eine Variationsbreite, mit der man nicht gerechnet hat. Bei PLATO bin ich persönlich am meisten gespannt auf die Alter. Das war für mich erstmal ein Erkenntnis zu lernen, als jemand, der aus der Planetenphysik kommt, dass die Alter von normalen Feldstern am Himmel sehr ungenau bekannt sind, nur auf dem Faktor 2, 3 oft bekannt sind, oder mindestens 50% unsicherheiten haben. Das war mir so gar nicht klar. Ich habe gedacht, meine Kollegen aus der Astrophysik, das sind normale Sterne, sind sehr gut verstanden.
Sie sind ja alles Experten.
Das liegt natürlich daran, dass das Interesse die Forschung weiter zu treiben, um das Alter dieses bestimmten Sterns jetzt so genau zu wissen, das war nicht nötig. Jetzt ist der Bedarf da, weil wenn der Stern ein Planeten-System hat, dann möchte man wissen, wie alt es ist. Das werden wir im Sinne von einer großen Statistik solcher Systeme, die mit Plato das erste Mal liefern können, und dort zu schauen, ob es typische Entwicklungen gibt vom Planeten-System. Wie sieht typischerweise ein Planeten-System oder ein Planet nach 2 Milliarden Jahren aus, nach 4 Milliarden Jahren aus? Wir werden ja auch Planeten-Systeme sehen, die älter sind als unseres. Diese Korrelation anzuschauen, das ist wirklich neu, das können wir heute nicht. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was rauskommt. Also es gibt eine Menge Meilensteine auf dem Weg hin zu der berühmten, wirklichen zweiten Erde, nicht die, die auf den Titelseiten kommen, sondern umher. Und da gibt es eine Menge Meilensteine, die spannend sind und Fragen beantworten, die wir heute haben, aber ständig neue Fragen stellen. Aber so ist Wissenschaft halt, das wird nicht langweilig.
Ja, ich wünsche Ihnen auf jeden Fall viel Erfolg, insbesondere bei der PLATO-Mission und natürlich auch bei der ganzen sonstigen Kooperation mit den anderen Missionen und Wissenschaftlern. Und bedanke mich an dieser Stelle für die Ausführung. War sehr interessant. Und ich bedanke mich auch fürs Zuhören. Das war es bei Raumzeit für heute. Wir hören uns bald wieder. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.